AGAIN OR AND ASSEMBLY BANKING
COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY JUNE TWENTY
FIFTH AM I BELIEVE.
ONE WE DO HAVE QUITE WERE SHORT
COURSE SHORT.
ONE WE'RE SHORT ONE A QUORUM SO
WE WILL START OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING --
AS ASIDE UNTIL WE HAVE.
AN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
AT WE DO HAVE ASSIGNING LESS
TIME AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH --
SENATOR GLACIER FOR SP
.
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE WE DIDN'T PUT
ANY TIME LIMITS ON IT BUT A WILL
ASK FOR BREVITY AND IN IN
COMMENTS THAT ARE MADE SO.
WITH THAT I WILL HAVE YOU BEGIN
SENATOR THE THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR LEMOND.
US SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY
FIVE I WOULD GIVE TO SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
MANY OF THE SAME PROTECTIONS
THAT OUR COUNTRY'S TRUTH IN
LENDING LAWS HAVE GIVEN CONSUMER
BORROWERS FOR MORE THAN HALF A
CENTURY.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE LENDERS
AND FINANCE COMPANIES. TO
PROVIDE CLEAR AND CONSISTENT
DISCLOSURE.
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WHEN THEY
OFFER THEM FINANCING AND WHEN
THEY CLOSE THE DEAL.
THIS INFORMATION WOULD HELP
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS UNDERSTAND
THE COST AND THE CONSEQUENCES.
BUT THE FINANCING OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
IN THE RAPIDLY EVOLVING
COMMERCIAL LENDING MARKET.
UNTIL NOW OUR TRUTH IN LENDING
LAWS APPLIED ONLY TO CONSUMER
FINANCE.
BUSINESS OWNERS WERE LEFT TO
FEND FOR THEMSELVES.
ON THE THEORY THAT THEY WERE
SOPHISTICATED MERCHANTS WHO
UNDERSTOOD THE WORLD OF FINANCE.
INCREASINGLY HOWEVER THAT IS NO
LONGER TRUE.
TODAY'S SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ARE OFTEN IMMIGRANT
ENTREPRENEURS STRUGGLING TO GET
THEIR ENTERPRISES OFF THE GROUND
WITH LITTLE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
FINANCE INDUSTRY.
TRADITIONAL BANKS MEANWHILE ARE
NO LONGER INTERESTED IN MAKING
SMALLER LOANS INSTEAD THAT SPACE
IS BEING FILLED BY INNOVATIVE
LENDERS OFFERING AN ARRAY OF
FINANCIAL OPTIONS.
THIS NEW ONLINE LENDING INDUSTRY
IS BRINGING CAPITAL TO PEOPLE
WHO BADLY NEEDED.
BUT THERE ARE ABUSES.
THIS BILL OFFERS A MODEST
MEASURE DISCLOSURE. TO HELP
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
IT WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA LEADER
IN PLACE IN THE INTERESTS OF
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
ON PAR WITH THE BIG PLAYERS IN
THE FINANCIAL INDUSTRY.
NOW IF YOU BORROWED MONEY FOR A
HOUSE OR A CAR SIMPLY TAKING OUT
A PERSONAL LOAN OR USED A CREDIT
CARD.
SEEN THE KIND OF DISCLOSURES
THAT THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE.
THEY TELL YOU HOW MUCH YOUR
BORROWING ALL THE FEES YOU'LL BE
PAYING.
HOW LONG WILL TAKE YOU TO REPAY
THE LOAN AND THE ANNUAL
ANNUALIZED INTEREST RATE?
THE LENDERS KNOW ALL THIS
INFORMATION ALREADY.
SOME OF THEM EVEN DISCLOSE IT IN
THE FINANCIAL MARKETS WHEN THEY
PACKAGE THEIR SMALL BUSINESS
LOANS AND SELL THEM AS
SECURITIES.
ALL WE'RE ASKING IS THAT THE
SCHOOL THAT THEY DISCLOSE THE
SAME INFORMATION TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS.
IT'S GOOD FOR WALL STREET SHOULD
BE GOOD ENOUGH FOR MAIN STREET.
THIS BILL IS UNDERGONE EXTENSIVE
CHANGES SINCE I FIRST INTRODUCED
IT IN FEBRUARY.
WE'VE TAKEN SUGGESTIONS FROM
MANY OF THE PLAYERS THEM IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND FOR MOST OF THE
OPPONENTS.
BUT WILL NEVER SATISFY EVERYONE.
MANY THE COMPANIES THAT LEAD TO
SMALL BUSINESS.
SIMPLY DO NOT WANT TO DISCLOSE
THE TERMS OF THEIR LOANS TO
THEIR CUSTOMERS.
AND MANY CONSUMER FINANCE
ADVOCATES WHAT THIS BILL TO
PRECISELY MERE THE LAWS THAT
GOVERN CONSUMER LENDING.
EVEN IF THAT MIGHT NOT BE
PRACTICAL FOR THE BUSINESS
LENDING MARKET.
LET ME FINISH UP I THINK WE'VE
STRUCK THE RIGHT BALANCE IN THIS
BILL REQUIRES CLEAR CONSISTENT
DISCLOSURE.
BUT DOES NOT RESTRICT THE KIND
OF FINANCING THE LENDERS CAN
OFFER.
AND WILL NOT LEAD TO ANY LOSS OF
ACCESS TO CAPITAL IN THE SMALL
BUSINESS WORLD.
WITH ME TODAY A ROBIN BLACK
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
AND I CATON HANSEN WHO WAS A CO
FOUNDER OF NAP DOT COM A COMPANY
THAT HELPS SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
NAVIGATE THE TRICKY NEW ONLINE
LENDING MARKETPLACE.
THANK YOU CHARLIE KNOWN IN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME. TO SHARE MY SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL WHEN I'M SKATING
HANSEN CO FOUNDER AND CHIEF
LEGAL COMPLIANCE OFFICER AT NAB
DOT COM.
NOW THE SMALL BUSINESS CREDIT
FINANCE PLATFORM USED BY MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND BUSINESS OWNERS IN THE
UNITED STATES INCLUDING THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND AND STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'M SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
HELPING SMALL BUSINESS BORROWERS
MORE EASILY COMPARE SOURCES OF
CAPITAL.
WHICH ULTIMATELY MEANS MORE
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
CONSIDER THE IMPACT THIS
LEGISLATION CAN HAVE SMALL
BUSINESS EMPLOYEES NEARLY HALF
OF ALL OF CALIFORNIA STATE
EMPLOYEES.
BUT ACCORDING TO THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES CLOSE EACH YEAR.
THE DATA SHOW TOP REASON THESE
BUSINESSES FELL.
IS DUE TO POOR CREDIT
ARRANGEMENTS.
I CO FOUNDED NOW FOR THE VERY
REASON OF BRINGING TRANSPARENCY
AND EFFICIENCY TO BUSINESS
FINANCING CREDIT.
I COME FROM SMALL BUSINESS
FAMILY MY GRANDFATHER STARTED A
POOL PLASTERING COMPANY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT MY COUSIN
RUNS THE SAME BUSINESS TODAY.
GROWING UP I WATCHED MY FATHER
WORK A FULL TIME JOB.
AND RUN SMALL BUSINESS ON THE
SIDE.
AS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER OF TWO
VISITS PRIOR TO NAV I'M
INTIMATELY AWARE OF THE HELP
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
I'VE SEEN OUR STRUGGLE ON A
DAILY BASIS AND HAVE BEEN IN
THEIR SHOES.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO FEEL
LIKE THE SUCCESSES.
OF YOUR BUSINESS HANG ON WHETHER
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT FINANCING OR
NOT.
TRANSPARENCY INEFFICIENCY VERY
IN THE BUSINESS LENDING WORLD.
IF YOU HAVEN'T EXPERIENCED IT
IT'S EASY TO SAY THE BORROWER
WILL FIGURE IT OUT.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING THE
REALITY IS THAT SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE NOT FINANCIAL EXPERTS.
THESE ARE NOT FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES ARE TALKING
ABOUT IN FACT. 75% OF ALL SMALL
BUSINESSES EMPLOY ONE OF FEWER
PEOPLE.
THESE ARE BUSINESSES WITHOUT A
FINANCE DEPARTMENT RUNNING A
BUSINESS AND HAVING TO PERFORM
FINANCE HR.
SELLS PRODUCT DEVELOPMENT.
IS EXTREMELY TAXING BUSINESS
OWNERS CAN'T SPEND HOURS AND
HOURS TRYING TO DECIPHER LOAN
DISCLOSURES.
THAT'S ONE ANNUALIZED COST OF
CAPITAL NEEDS TO BE A PART OF
THIS LEGISLATION.
THE BEST METHOD WE HAVE TO
CREATE A QUICK APPLES TO APPLES
COST COMPARISON.
WE'VE HAD IS PROTECTION FOR
CONSUMERS FOR YEARS IT'S ALREADY
SETTLED LAW.
THE BILL'S OPPOSITION CLAIM AN
ANNUALIZED COST OF CAPITAL WILL
CONFUSE BORROWERS THE FACT IS
THAT AN ANNUALIZED RATE WHICH
INCLUDES ALL COSTS.
WE'LL SIMPLY REVEAL HOW
EXPENSIVE SOME OF THESE PRODUCTS
CAN BE.
IF THIS FORCES THEM TO EXPLAIN
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SHORT
TERM VERSUS LONG TERM CAPITAL.
AND THE EFFECT THAT HAS ON AN
ANNUALIZED RATE AND SO BE IT.
IT'S BETTER THAN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM THAT PUTS ALL THE BURDEN
ON THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNER.
WE'VE ALREADY AGREED THAT ARE
THAT USING AN ANNUALIZED RATE IS
THE BEST WAY FOR CONSUMERS TO
COMPARE LOANS WHY SHOULD BE
DIFFERENT FOR SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS.
MOST REPUTABLE BUSINESS LETTERS
ALREADY PROVIDE AN ANNUALIZED
RATE BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHAT'S
THE BEST WAY FOR A BORROWER TO
COMPARE LOANS.
IN TERMS ALTERNATE BLENDER SUCH
AS CABBAGE ON JACK IN SMART
BUSINESS LOANS.
ARE USING TOOLS SUCH A SMART BOX.
TO PROVIDE NECESSARY DISCLOSURES.
THEY KNOW IT'S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO THIS BILL IS JUST A WAY TO
STANDARDIZE AND REQUIRE THIS
ACROSS THE INDUSTRY.
SO THAT THE FEW BAD APPLES CAN'T
CONTINUE TO SEE BUSINESS OWNERS
THIS BILL ISN'T ABOUT REGULATING
THE CASA BUSINESS LOANS ARE
TRYING TO HARM BUSINESS LINERS
WHICH WE WOULDN'T SUPPORT.
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE TIMES WHEN
A TRIPLE DIGIT ANNUALISED RATE
IS A SMART DECISION FOR BUSINESS
OWNER.
BUT THE BUSINESS OWNER DESERVES
TO HAVE A CLEAR WAY OF COMPARING
PRODUCTS AND KNOWING HOW MUCH
IT'S GOING TO COST THEM.
IF THE TERMS ARE TRANSPARENT A
BUSINESS OWNER MAKES A BAD
DECISION THAT IT'S ON THEM. TO
CLAIM EDUCATING A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER ON THE TRUE COST OF
CAPITAL IS A HARM TO THEM IS
SIMPLY RIDICULOUS.
UNLIKE THE OPPONENTS WE HAVE
NOTHING TO GAIN BY PASSING THIS
BILL WE JUST KNOW IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
WE ALSOBELIEVE IT CAN BECOME A
MODEL FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND
WILL POSITIVELY IMPACT MILLIONS
OF BUSINESS.
OWNERS THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES.
ON BEHALF OF THE HUNDRED TEAM
MEMBERS IT NOW.
ALONG WITH OUR THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
CUSTOMERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I URGE YOU TO PASS THE BILL
THANK YOU.
I WILL ASK FOR A QUORUM AND IF
WE CAN JUST BEFORE WE FINISH UP
IF WE CAN JUST CALL FORM.
HE WON'T HEAR LIMON HERE CHEN.
ACOSTA HERE COSTA HERE BURKE
[inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL HERE GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER HERE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON HERE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH HERE STONE
[inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ROBIN
BLACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION.
I'M WE ARE A NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING SMALL BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF YOU WERE AT OUR LUNCHEON
LAST WEEK WITH YOUR HONOREES AND
WE LOVE SMALL BUSINESS WE
CELEBRATE SMALL BUSINESS.
AND WE REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW ACCESS TO
CAPITAL IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
CHALLENGE FACING SMALL BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA AND START UP
BUSINESSES IN PARTICULAR IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS HAS ALREADY BEEN STATED.
ARM THAT TRANSPARENCY THAT THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE FOR OUGHT
SMALL BUSINESSES LOOKING FOR
THAT KIND OF CAPITAL SPECIAL IN
THE NEW MARKETS ONLINE.
IS SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT I WON'T REPEAT
EVERYTHING THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
SAID.
BUT INFORMING THE CONSUMERS
GIVING HIM THE TRANSPARENCY THAT
IS ALREADY THERE FOR CONSUMER
LOANS IN CALIFORNIA PROVIDING IT
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES MANY OF
THEM WHO.
ARE MANY OF WHOM ARE NOT AS
SOPHISTICATED AND AND THE
FINANCE OF LAWS AND THE
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE TRUE COST
OF A LOAN OR BORROWING MONEY CAN
BE.
THIS WILL GO A LONG WAYS TO HELP
THOSE AND CESSATION WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND WHERE CHAIR I
FOUND [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
I SUPPORT DYING.
WE'LL START WITH SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR AT NAME
AND ASSOCIATION.
ON BEHALF THE SMALL BUSINESS
FINANCE ASSOCIATION SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT THOSE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
FALL OF GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS AND PATTERSON IN A
MINUTE PARTNER AT OR ACCOUNTANTS
AYCLIFFE AN OUTSIDE COUNSEL FOR
THE INNOVATIVE LENDING PLATFORM
ASSOCIATION.
I'M PHILLIP COMING THEATER IN
THE ROUND HERE [inaudible]
AND WE'RE HERE REGRETFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB --
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE BECAUSE OF
THE INCLUSION OF THE UNTESTED
NEW METRIC THE ECC THAT ISN'T
WELL.
THE AYE OKAY IS THE LEADING
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR SMALL
BUSINESS LENDING AND SERVICE
COMPANIES AND OUR MEMBERS
INCLUDE ON DECK CAPITAL CABBAGE
AND THE BUSINESS BACKER.
I WANT TO START BY MAKING IT
CLEAR THAT WE DO NOT OPPOSE S.
B. TWELVE THIRTY FIVES OBJECTIVE
HERE AND ITS ATTEMPTS TO CREATE
DISCLOSURES ON WE ACTUALLY
SUPPORT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACTUALLY.
AT THE WITNESS FROM NOT
MENTIONED ALL MEMBERS OF THE I
OP A ALREADY PREPARED TO PROVIDE
BORROWERS WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
DISCLOSURE.
SCHOOL DOES NOT BOX LOOKS LOW
BUT LIKE THE SCHUMER BOX OR FOR
THOSE OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
CHEERIOS THE NUTRITIONAL LABEL
ON THE BACK AYE OF THAT --
WE SPENT ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
DEVELOPING ABOUT THE SMART BOX
AND WORKED IN CONSULTATION WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES TO IDENTIFY THE
METRICS THAT WERE MOST
MEANINGFUL TO THEM WHEN THEY
WERE TRYING TO COMPARE BETWEEN
HIGH FINANCIAL PRODUCTS.
AND THEN YOU CAN SEE THOSE
METRICS REFLECTED HERE WE HAVE
TOTAL COST OF CAPITAL AT THE TOP
WHICH USUALLY RANKED AS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST MOST --
MEANINGFUL FOR FOLKS.
WE DISCLOSED APR I ANNUAL
PERCENTAGE RATE AVERAGE MONTHLY
PAYMENTS SENSE ON DOLLAR AND
WHETHER THERE ARE ANY PREPAYMENT
PENALTIES.
I'M SO I'M SURE YOU PROBABLY
CAN'T SEE THIS FROM HERE I'M
HAPPY TO PROVIDE IRAQ COPIES OF
PEOPLE LIKE TO SEE IT --
MORE CLOSELY SO WE REALLY WE DID
MAKE THESE DISCLOSURES
VOLUNTARILY BECAUSE WE WANT OUR
SMALL BUSINESS CUSTOMERS TO BE
INFORMED SO THAT THEY CAN PICK
THE RIGHT FINANCING PRODUCT FOR
THEIR USE CASE.
AND WE DO BELIEVE AND I THINK AS
THE AUTHOR.
AND BUT WE STRONGLY --
OPPOSE THE TWELFTH SIR S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY FIVES INCLUSION OF
THIS UNTESTED NEW METRIC THE ACC
OR E. ACC --
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT IT WILL
FRUSTRATE RATHER THAN FACILITATE
AN APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON
ACROSS PRODUCTS.
AND HERE'S WHY.
I'M A LITTLE [inaudible]
CARD.
AS YOU CAN SEE APR AND ACC LOOK
A LOT ALIKE.
THEY'RE BOTH PERCENTAGES.
I'M WHICH IS GOING TO CAUSE
CONFUSION FOR BORROWERS AND
THESE TWO HERE APR AND ECC.
ARE THIS ARE FOR THE EXACT SAME
LOAN ONE SIXTH MONTH FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR LOAN WITH THE
EXACT SAME INTERESTS AND FEES.
APR THIRTY THREE POINT SIX ACC
TWENTY TWO POINT.
SIX THREE ONCE LOOKING A LOT
HIGHER THAN THE OTHER FOR THE
EXACT SAME LOAN WITH THE SAME
COSTS.
SO THIS IS BASICALLY ACC JUST
LIKE IS A PR BUT SMALLER --
THAT'S WHAT SORT OF LIKE
INTRODUCING A NEW FEDERAL FOOD
MEASUREMENT FOR EXAMPLE WHERE I
CAN LOOK AT THE SENATE BOND AND
SAY.
OH DOESN'T HAVE NINE HUNDRED
CALORIES ANYMORE IT HAS SIX
HUNDRED CALORIES --
AND I THINK JUST LIKE THAT WOULD
DRIVE PEOPLE TO MAKE BAD FOOD
DECISIONS ON THIS A C. IT'S
GONNA TENSELY MISLEAD FARMERS
INTO CHOOSING POTENTIALLY MORE
EXPENSIVE PRODUCTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO CONFLATE APR.
AND ECC THE DANGER IS GOING TO
OCCUR HERE BECAUSE BORROWERS ARE
GOING TO BE COMPARING DIFFERENT
PRODUCTS ONE COULD WITH A PR AND
ONE ACC.
LOTS OF THINGS ARE STILL GOING
TO BE QUITE AND APR THE SCHUMER
BOX IN YOUR CREDIT CARD IS STILL
GOING TO HAVE A PR.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THE CREDIT
THAT --
SMALL BUSINESS CUSTOMERS ORGANIC.
P. R. THIRTY THREE THE ONE THAT
SAYS THIS AND IT'S JUST LOWER
IT'S LIKE BUYING THE CINNABAR
UNDERTAKEN SUDDENLY YOU'RE GONNA
PICK THE ONE THAT LOOKS LOWER --
EVEN THOUGH IN FACT IT'S NOT.
THE ACTUALLY LESS EXPENSIVE
PRODUCT IT'S JUST A DIFFERENT
METRIC ENTIRELY --
SO THE PROBLEM IS GOING TO I
THINK NOT GO AWAY OVER TIME WITH
THIS BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO LIVE IN AN ECOSYSTEM.
WHERE APR REMAINS?
YOU KNOW THE PROMINENT METRICS
SO PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE TRYING
TO REALLY DOING APPLES TO
ORANGES COMPARISONS BETWEEN APR
AN ECC.
ACROSS THIS ISN'T ACTUALLY JUST
SPECULATION ON WE'D SPENT I
THINK I MENTIONED A LOT OF
HOMEWORK WHEN WE DEVELOPED SMART
BOX.
OVER EIGHTEEN MONTHS ONE OF
THINGS WE DID IS ACTUALLY
CONSIDERED PUTTING A SECOND
PERCENTAGE METRIC THE AIR INTO
THE SMART BOX THAT WOULD HAVE
HAD.
WHEN MORE PERCENTAGE HERE AND
WHEN WE SHARED THAT WITH SMALL
BUSINESS CUSTOMERS IT
IMMEDIATELY CAUSE CONFUSION
THERE LIKE WHICH ONE'S THE REAL?
ONE WHICH ONE IS THE RIGHT ONE
AND SO IT JUST LED TO A TONIC
QUESTIONS AND SO WE ULTIMATELY
SAID.
ONLY ONE PERCENTAGE BASED METRIC
ON THIS BECAUSE IT'S JUST GOING
TO CONFUSE PEOPLE.
AND SO I THINK THE CONCERN FOR
US IS THAT WHERE YOU ARE NOW IN
A POSITION AS THE AISLE PSA.
OF HAVING TO DROP APR ENTIRELY
AND REPLACED IT WITH THE THIS
NEW METRIC WHICH IS UNTESTED
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE I DON'T
KNOW ANYONE WHO'S EVER USED IT I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE BEEN ANY
STUDIES.
ON WHETHER OR NOT IT ACTUALLY
KIND OF WORKS OVERTIME.
SO WE REALLY COULDN'T REPLACE IT
OR WE CAN GO BACK TO SITUATION
WHERE WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
HAVE TO PERCENTAGES ON THE SMART
BOX AGAIN.
WHICH WE KNOW BASED ON OUR OWN
BACK DOES CAUSE CONFUSION FOR
PEOPLE SO WE CLOSING.
WE SUPPORT THE CONCEPT HERE AYE
WE BELIEVE IN TRANSPARENCY AND
DISCLOSURE BUT WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED THAT THIS MATTER WILL
BE CONFUSING FOR PEOPLE
INHABITING THREE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR LIMON AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TESTIMONY TODAY REGARDING S. B..
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE MY NAME IS
KATE FISHER AND I AM HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMERCIAL
FINANCE COALITION.
A GROUP OF RESPONSIBLE FINANCE
COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE CAPITAL
TO SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZE
BUSINESSES THROUGH INNOVATIVE
METHODS.
WE SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS
TO PROVIDE BUSINESS FINANCING
DISCLOSURES.
CFC MEMBERS ALREADY DISCLOSED
ACOSTA FINANCING AND WELCOME ALL
OF THE DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
OF S. B. TWELVE THIRTY FIVE
EXCEPT.
FOR ONE THAT IS THE ESTIMATED
ANALYZE COST OF CAPITAL
DISCLOSURE. FOR CLARITY WE DO
NOT OPPOSE DISCLOSURE INSTEAD
WE'RE ADVOCATING FOR AN
EFFECTIVE AND ACCURATE
DISCLOSURE.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT REQUIRING
ANY ANALYZE PERCENTAGE FOR
FINANCING THAT IS NOT ALONE.
WILL MISS CHARACTERIZE THE
UNDERLYING TRANSACTION AND
SENATOR GLAZERS BILL RECOGNIZES
THAT REQUIRING AN ESTIMATED
ANALYZE COST OF CAPITAL
DISCLOSURE DOES NOT MAKE SENSE
FOR OTHER NON LOAN PRODUCTS.
SO JUST COMMERCIAL LEASING OR
INVOICE FACTORING.
COMMERCIAL LEASING IS COMPLETELY
EXEMPT FROM S. B..
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE AND INVOICE
FACTORING IS EXEMPT FROM THE
ANALYZE COST OF CAPITAL
DISCLOSURE.
THAT IS BECAUSE COMMERCIAL
LEASING AN INVOICE FACTORING ARE
NOT LOANS.
BUT S. B. TWELVE THIRTY FIVE
PROPOSES TO REQUIRE AN
ANNUALIZED ACOSTA CAPITAL
DISCLOSURE FOR FUTURE
RECEIVABLES FACTORING.
ALSO NOT ALONE.
THIS IS A LOGICAL.
FUTURES HE WILL SPECTRUM IS
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT FROM
ALONE.
THE BUSINESS PART PAYS ONLY A
PERCENTAGE OF ITS RECEIVABLES
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WILDFIRES SWEPT
ACROSS CALIFORNIA LAST FALL A
BUSINESS THAT WAS DAMAGED THEY
COULD NOT OPERATE WOULD OWE
NOTHING.
BECAUSE THE TRANSACTION IS NOT%
ALONE ANY APR OR ANALYZE COST OF
CAPITAL DISCLOSURE WHICH WOULD
ONLY CONFUSE AND MISLEAD SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
I'M VERY OPTIMISTIC THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE WAY IN
PROVIDING BUSINESSES WITH
DISCLOSURES THAT ARE HOPEFUL AND
NOT MISLEADING. FOR EXAMPLE THE
DISCLOSURE AYE IN SP TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THE DISCLOSURE OF TOTAL DOLLAR
COST OF FINANCING WHICH IS
CURRENTLY IN THE BILL AND
SECTION TWENTY TWO ITO TO BE
[inaudible]
THREE THANK.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITIONPLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME [inaudible]
AND ASSOCIATION.
RIGHT HEARING ARE SEEN THEN I'M
MEMBERS WE WILL TURN IT OVER TO
YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR THOUGHTS
ASSIGNED NUMBER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I I WAS HEARING THE TESTIMONY
ABOUT APR VERSES A CC.
AND IT WAS ALMOST LIKE YOU I IT
WAS SOUND LIKE HE WAS APPLES AND
ORANGES.
RIGHT COMPARED BETWEEN THE TWO
SO AS LONG AS THE CONSUMER OR IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE THE THE
BUSINESS OWNER THAT WASN'T
SEEKING A COMMERCIAL LOAN.
WAS AWARE THAT --
THEY WERE APPLES AND ORANGES
THEN THIS LONG AS THEY WERE
ALIGNING THE APPLES TOGETHER OR
THE ORANGES TOGETHER.
AND COMPARING THE RIGHT RATES
THEN IT WOULD.
THERE WOULD BE CONFUSION IS THAT
RIGHT [inaudible]
THAT IF.
FORGOT PASSED THE SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN THEM AND ACTUALLY SORT
OF DIE AGAIN --
THEY COULD POTENTIALLY SEC ACC
IS FORM IS BASICALLY COMPUTER
COMPLETELY DIFFERENTLY AND IS IT
SIGNED TO BE A DIFFERENT METRIC.
I THINK THE HARD PART IS WHEN
YOU JUST SEE IF YOUR ACC WE'VE
SEE RATES PEOPLE ARE MAKING
QUICK DECISIONS AND I THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO SEE. 36% 23%
AND JUST.
GO WITH THAT WHEN THE OTHER
THINGS I THINK THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC HERE IS THAT THE
UNDERLYING DIFFERENCES I WON'T
EVEN BEGIN TO TRY TO EXPLAIN
BECAUSE TRYING TO SAY WHICH
WOULD WE KNOW.
TRYING TO SAY WITH Y. APR IS IS
COMPUTED ONE WAY AND Y. ACC'S
COMPUTER THE OTHER WAY.
IS GOING TO BE COMPLICATED AND
TAKE UP A LOT OF TIME ON THE
PHONE WHERE PEOPLE TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHICH ONE'S THE REAL
ONE THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
LOOKING AT.
SHIRT SO IF WE WERE COMPARING
PRODUCTS.
WHETHER THAT PRODUCT IF FROM --
THREE TO WAS USING A P. ARE.
THAT I WOULD HAVE A FAIR
COMPARISON BETWEEN.
SO IF I HAD ALL THREE PROVIDERS
ALSO PROVIDING AN A CC.
AND THEY WERE BEING COMPARED
STRICTLY AMONGST STCC THERE
WOULD BE A FAIR COMPARISON IT
WOULD BE AND I THINK THE
CHALLENGE THAT THEY WILL HAVE IT
DOING STRAIGHT UP IN RENO REAL
TIME AIR APPLES TO APPLES IS
GOING TO BE.
THAT CREDIT CARDS WILL NEVER BE
USING AN ACC THERE RIGHT THERE
OFTEN WONDER TEAL I YOU KNOW
PROGRAM WITH THAT WITH THE SHAME
OF OXEN ARE GOING TO CONTINUES
IF YOU ARE.
NOT A SMALL BUSINESSES RELY AND
NOT SO THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE IT
OUT ORANGE AN APPLE MAYBE A
COUPLE APPLES IF YOU PAIR NOT
JUST APPLES AND ORANGES.
ELEMENT RE-ATTEMPT. TO DEPART
FROM AN AP ARE AND COME UP WITH
THIS NEW UNTESTED ACC --
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION NOT
ALTHOUGH I WOULD NICK AGREE WITH
THE UNTESTED PART BUT I
ORIGINALLY IN MY BILL I DID HAVE
A PR AND OPPONENTS CAME IN AND
SAID.
WE DON'T WANT YOU TO HAVE A P.
R..
BECAUSE I A. P. R. CHANGES WITH
EVERY PAYMENT YOU MAKE CHANGES
THE NUMBER AND THEY CITY CREATES
LEGAL VULNERABILITY.
OF FOR US TO AT A TO USE APRS
OKAY THE PURPOSE HERE IS NOT TO
CURTAIL SMALL BUSINESS LENDING.
OUT WE NEED THAT CAPITAL OUT
THERE THE ONLY ISSUE I WANT US
DISCLOSURE I DON'T TO CREATE
LEGAL LIABILITY.
SO I SAID OKAY BECAUSE AP ARE
CHANGES WITH EVERY PAYMENT LET'S
COME UP WITH ANOTHER AT METRIC
THAT'S NOT AND I KNEW METRIC BUT
A METRIC IN THE IN THE WORLD OF
BUSINESS THAT SAYS.
LET'S TAKE A SNAPSHOT IN TIME.
OF WHAT THAT WOULD COST OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE ANNUALIZED
COST OF CAPITAL ACC.
IT'S NOT BASED ON WHAT YOU MAKE
MORE PAYMENTS THIS MONTH OR LESS
PAYMENTS NEXT MONTH.
IT'S ONE SNAPSHOT.
THEREBY PROVIDING A FAIR
ESTIMATE WITHOUT LEGAL
VULNERABILITY AND A VERY SIMPLE
STANDARD AND THAT'S WHERE A CC
HAS COME FROM.
SO HOW DO YOU SAID WITHOUT LEGAL
OF VULNERABILITY BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE CONCERNS
OF A CC IS THAT.
YOU COULD DRAW A FIGURE OUT
THERE AND IT ACTUALLY NOT BE THE
EXACT FIGURE THAT CREATES
LIABILITY ON THE LENDERS PART
WHAT WHAT HAVE YOU DONE TO BE
ABLE -- TO
MEDICAID THAT LIES IN THE BILL
THAT SAYS AN ESTIMATE IT SAYS AN
ESTIMATED ANNUALIZED COST OF
CAPITAL SO THAT'S THE REQUIRE
DISCLOSURE AND THAT THAT.
IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK
PROVIDES FOR UP APPROPRIATE
LEGAL PROTECTION FOR ANY LENDER
WHO'S PROVIDING THAT CAPITAL
THAT PROPOSAL TO WITHIN THEIR
DISCLOSURE YOU'RE SAYING IF YOU
PUT ESTIMATE ON THEIR THAN THAT
WOULD.
HELP MITIGATE AND I CERTAINLY
HAVEN'T HEARD ANY CRITICISM
SINCE THE ON THAT ON THOSE TERMS
IN REGARD ACC RIGHT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR THOUGHTS
RESTORATION.
THANK YOU ENSURE BUT I DO WANT
TO SAY THAT I KNOW IS REPUBLICAN
ONE THINGS THAT.
IS ALWAYS A CONCERN IS
GOVERNMENT OVERREACH ON THIS
BILL DOESN'T DO THAT YOU KNOW MY
OPINION THIS THAT BILL ONE WHICH
IS HELPFUL FOR THE LENDER ITSELF
THE CONSUMER.
IS INFORMATION THAT IS HEALTH
FORM WHICH WILL PREVENT THEM
FROM MAKING DECISIONS THAT WILL
BE FINANCIAL DURESS.
OF FOR THEM IN THE FUTURE SO I
APPRECIATE BRING THIS BILL FORD
AND SO WITH THAT SAID I'D BE
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
[inaudible]
WE HAVE
YEAH SO I I JUST CURIOUS FOR THE
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL IF YOUR
POST -- ACC
IN YOUR POST A PARENTS ARE
METRIC THAT YOU WOULD RECOMMEND
AND SUGGEST.
WE ARE ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF IP
TO DISCLOSE AYE APR NOW SO WE'RE
NOT OPPOSED TO IT HERE THINK
THERE WERE PEOPLE ON IN THE IN
THE IN THE DESK WE DON'T LET
THEM SPEAK.
YEAH THANK YOU THIRD OF TOTAL
COST TOTAL DOLLAR COST OF
FINANCING WHICH IS NOT A
PERCENTAGE BUT SAYS TELLS THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER THIS IS HOW
MUCH THE MONEY WILL COST.
THAT IS THE BEST METRIC AND
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE ON THE THE
GOAL IS TO PROVIDE OF A
MEASUREMENT THAT WORKS ACROSS
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS SO THAT
MEASUREMENT WORKS WHETHER IT'S A
LOAN OR A SALE.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY
REQUIRED TO BE DISCLOSED.
BUT NO IT'S I MEAN NOT NOT BY BY
LAW IT IS REQUIRED TO BE
DISCLOSED --
BY CONTRACT SO THAT THE THAT
CUSTOMER UNDERSTANDS WHAT
THEY'RE YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF
BODIES IN THERE GETTING AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE GROUP I REPRESENT.
DO UP PROVIDE DISCLOSURES LIKE
THAT.
YOU KNOW AND DID A SURVEY OF
SMALL BUSINESSES PART OF THAT
TOTAL COST OF CAPITAL WAS
SOMETHING WE DOLLARS AND DOLLARS
OUT THE IN THE DAY THAT IS WHAT
IS MOST MEANINGFUL TO THEM I'M
NOT SUGGESTING YOU KNOW ANALYZE
METRIC OR WHATEVER.
THE PROBLEM WITH ANALYZE METRICS
GENERALLY IS THAT THE SHORTER
THE TERM OF THE LOAN THEY JUST
LOOK A LOT IT THIS STARTS TO
FALL APART AND PER YEAR --
BUT I BUT TO THE POINT THAT THAT
THAT YOU MADE THAT BOTTLE OF
CAPITAL IS SOMETHING THAT
BUSINESS OWNER SAY IS THE METRIC
IT'S WHITES AT THE TOP OF OUR
SMALL BOX [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER.
JUST WANTED TO GET SOME CLARITY --
NOW THIS SMART BOX THAT YOU HAVE --
HOW LONG HAVE YOU HAD THE SMART
BOTTOM IS A SOMETHING THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE ACCESS TO WOULD
HAVE TO YEARS OR SOMETHING NEW
WE LAUNCHED A IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SO IT'S BEEN
AROUND FOR TWO YEARS?
OKAY EN AND BUT IT'S NOT
REQUIRED IS NOT IT'S A VOLUNTARY
INDUSTRY MODEL ANYBODY WHO JOINS
I'LL PA MUST DISCLOSE THAT AS
PART OF THAT MEMBERSHIP SO.
YOU HAVE SOME OF THE LARGER
LANDERS LIKE ON TECH AND CABBAGE
USING IT ON BUT IT IS NOT
MANDATORY IS NOT MADE BY THE
GOVERNMENT.
HUMPIN.
OKAY SO THEREFORE IT'S KIND OF
AN UN EVEN THING IN TERMS OF WHO
HAS ACCESS TO IT WITH THAT
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT THE REAL COST
OF THEIR LOANS ARE YEAH.
THERE'S NOT THERE'S NO MANDATE
TO MAKE THESE DISCLOSURES
CONTENT AND THE INDUSTRY
INITIALLY WAS A POST APR.
AND I ASSUME WE STILL ARE I
WOULD IMAGINE.
HASTHERE BEEN SOME REVELATION
EVERY.
IT IS OF THE COMPANIES THAT
FINANCING COMPANIES THAT DON'T
OFFER LOANS BUT OFFER A TYPE OF
FACT DREAM PROGRAM.
SO THEY ARE OPPOSED TO ANY TYPE
OF ANALYZE METRIC BECAUSE THOSE
TYPES OF TRANSACTIONS DON'T HAVE
A TERM.
BUT THE THE BUSINESS ONLY PAYS A
PERCENTAGE OF ITS REVENUE AS
THAT REVENUES CREATED.
SO THAT THE TRANSACTION WILL
TAKE AS LONG AS IT TAKES AS LONG
AS IT TAKES A BUSINESS TO
GENERATE THE REVENUE.
THAT THEY WILL THEN DELIVER TO
THE COMPANY --
AND I ASSUME THAT ANY NEW SYSTEM
THAT YOU COME UP WITH WILL BE
UNTESTED I MEAN THAT'S THE
NATURE OF SOME NEW --
IF IT DOES NOT IT WOULD BE OLD
RATHER THAN.
IT BEING SOMETHING NEW SOME NOT
NECESSARY PERSUADED BY THE
UNTESTED ELEMENT OF THAT.
I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE SOME
TRANSPARENT OUT THAT MUCH
TRANSPARENCY IN TERMS OF
COMMERCIAL LOANS I JUST ASSUME
EVERYBODY HIT TRANSPARENCY IN
NEW WITH IT ALONE COST AND AND
SO I FOUND IT.
RATHER INCREDIBLE THAT THAT IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN NOT SURE I'M
CONVINCED ACC IS THE BEST THING
BUT I AM HURTING BY TELL ME
THING ELSE.
I KNOW PEOPLE DON'T LIKE A PR
VOTE MUCH BUT I THINK THAT HER
THAT ACC SO HORRIBLE.
I'M PROBABLY GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS AS IT GOES FORWARD WITH
HOPES THAT WHATEVER PROBLEM
THERE IS YOU GUYS WORK IT OUT
BEFORE IT GETS TO THE FLOOR OF
NOT SURE.
NOVEL FOR ON THE FLOOR BUT I
WANT TO I DO WANT TO GIVE LIFE
TO THIS SO THEY CAN THE
CONVERSATION CAN CONTINUE
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
SAW SECOND THE MOTION THAT WAS
MADE.
THANK YOU NUMBER WEBER AND I
THINK WE HAVE A SITE NUMBER
ACOSTA AND THEN A SUMMER GABER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AYE AYE AYE.
CAN I APPRECIATE DISCOURSE TODAY
YOU KNOW APPRECIATE --
CENTER GLAZER.
COMING BY AND WE HAVE THINGS.
SIGNIFICANT CONVERSATIONS AROUND
THIS IT IS A COMPLICATED ISSUE
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TO THE
END.
INTRODUCING A NEW METRIC BY
WHICH UP.
ZOOMER IS WHICH I KNOW WE'RE
CALLING THEM BUSINESS OWNERS BUT
THEY'RE STILL PEOPLE ON THE
STOCK OF CREDIT CARDS AND AUTO
LOANS AND MORTGAGES.
AND ALL THESE THINGS ARE
CALCULATED SOMEWHAT DIFFERENTLY
SO I THINK THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE --
FOR MORE DISCLOSURE --
I I SHARE MY COLLEAGUES ARE FROM
SAN DIEGO SYMPATHIES THAT THIS
MAY TOP BE THE BEST ANSWER --
BECAUSE THESE THINGS ARE ALL
CALCULATED DIFFERENTLY WHETHER
IT'S TRUE FACT YOU KNOW.
A TRADITIONAL FACTORING --
WHETHER IT'S FUTURE RECEIVABLES
UP MY CONCERN.
HAS BEEN AND THAT.
IS IT AS A CONSUMER AND THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER BECAUSE ARE
STILL INDIVIDUALS ARE STILL
PEOPLE.
THAT YOU'RE ON ONE SIDE OF THE
FENCE YOU'RE GETTING A CREDIT
CARD OFFER A SMALL BUSINESS LOAN
OFFER FROM ONE ENTITY ON YOUR
CREDIT CARD IT POPPED UP ON MY
SCREEN FROM ONE OF MY BANKS
STATEMENTS THE OTHER DAY --
AND THEN OVER ON THIS SIDE WE'RE
DOING SOMETHING ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT AND I'M CONCERNED THAT
THERE WILL BE CONFUSION THERE I
THINK [inaudible]
BOB.
YOU HAVE MADE ATTEMPTS. TO TO TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THIS --
I THINK THAT WE NEED.
GOOD DISCLOSURE IN THIS ROUND --
CAN YOU TELL ME THE THE JUST FOR
THE RECORD THE SUNSET DATE ON
THIS WE HAVE A SENSE OUT OF WHAT.
VOTE FOR YOUR YEARS SO.
I'M NOT THRILLED WITH.
NO DISCLOSURE NOT SURE THIS IS
1100% THE WAY TO GO --
BUT I I THINK THAT GIVEN THE
FACT THAT A PR DOESN'T WORK ACC
MAY NOT WORK WE GOTTA TRY
SOMETHING --
YOU'VE.
SEEM TO HAVE --
BE VERY INTERESTED IN MAKING
SOMETHING WORK SO I'D REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO WORK WITH YOU
KNOW THE OPPOSITION TO TRY TO
FIX THINGS --
TO THEIR LIKING AND AND REALLY
TRY TO FIND SOMETHING THAT.
THAT SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS CAN
SINK THEIR TEETH INTO YOU KNOW
MAYBE YOU'RE GONNA INVENT
SOMETHING NEW HERE THAT'S GOING
TO CARRY THROUGHOUT THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY I DON'T KNOW.
UP I'M NOT A HUNT PERCENT
COMFORTABLE WITH.
THE DISCREPANCIES THAT SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE GOING TO BE
FINDING THEMSELVES BUT IT'S A
STEP AND SO I'M GOING TO BE.
ARE WE GOING TO BE TAKING A LOOK
AT THIS I I'M I MAY LAYOFF AT
THIS MOMENT.
BUT I'M LEANING TOWARD
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY JUST
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS BUT I'M RESERVING JUDGMENT
ON THE FLOOR. FOR WHAT THE FINAL
PRODUCT IS THANK YOU.
AS AN ADVOCATE.
AND A SUMMER LA. ONE YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO OUR ASSOCIATE MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN DIEGO I
APPRECIATE SENATOR GLAZER YOUR
YOUR EFFORT TO DO THIS AND BRING
TRANSPARENCY TO THE SPACE I
THINK THAT'S A VERY WORTHWHILE
OBJECTIVE --
I'M INCLINED TO SUPPORT YOU
TODAY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AND AGAIN A RESERVE
JUDGMENT ON THE FLOOR JUST.
TO HELP MYSELF --
YEAH I UNDERSTAND THIS WILL.
THANK YOU I'M CHAIR --
AND CENTER THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL TODAY --
I'M READING IT FURIOUSLY AFTER
BEING SUBSTITUTED IN JUST A FEW
A FEW HOURS AGO --
CORRECT BUT IT HAS THE MEDIUM
SIZED BOX RIGHT AND I KNOW
USUALLY YOU BRING OF COMMONSENSE
APPROACH HERE LEGISLATING OUR
STRUGGLING WITH THE CONVERSATION
TURNS TO DEFER METRICS I THINK I
HEARD THAT PART OF IT.
FORGIVE ME IF I MISSED THE
PORTION WHEN YOU ADDRESS THE ONE
OF THE OTHER THINGS IN MY QUICK
READ OF THIS --
WAS SOMEWHAT TROUBLING TO ME IS
THE FOURTH PAGE OF THE OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ANALYSIS TALKING
ABOUT THE THE ABILITY OR LACK
THEREOF TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT.
HOW OR ENFORCEMENT --
ON THIS --
IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT IF
WE'RE LOOKING OUT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES WOULD HAVE TO HAVE
SOME WAY OF TRYING TO ACTUALLY
ENFORCE WHAT YOU TRY TO DO WITH
THIS BILL IN THE IT'S I WOULD
SAY.
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ME TO VOTE
FOR SOMETHING THAT SAYS THAT
WHAT IT SAYS HERE IN TERMS OF
HAVING.
THE THEIR SILENT OR MORE IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE.
TO IT -- WHO
HOME FOLKS?
WHY THE BILL'S ITS CURRENT STATE
IT WITH THESE COMMENTS?
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU LA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER --
THERE ARE SOME THAT WOULD LIKE
TO REGULATE AND DIE AND THE
THING THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT.
THAT WE'D RATHER START WITH THE
STEP OF DISCLOSURE AND NOT
LICENSING AND NOT REGULATION IN
THE HOPE WOULD BE THAT THE
MARKETPLACE CAN ACT
APPROPRIATELY DISCLOSED
APPROPRIATELY.
AYE AND THAT CAN BE THE END OF
IT.
UP BUT UNDER CURRENT LAW IF YOU
HAVE A DAY CONTRACT DISPUTE YOU
HAVE THE SAME REVENUES UNDER
THIS BILL IS PROPOSES YOU WOULD
IN ANY OTHER CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
YOU HAVE TODAY.
AND OUR PUBLIC LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS HAVE THAT SAME ABILITY
IF THEY CITY.
OF VIOLATIONS THAT TO ENGAGE IS
APPROPRIATE ITSELF SO.
THE SAME REMEDIES THAT EXISTS
TODAY --
WITH -- WHO
YOU KNOW ARE ARE IN PLACE WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF REGULATION?
AND I IT WAS MY VIEW THAT I
COULD YOU GET FOLKS FROM ALL
SIDES ON THESE KINDS OF THINGS
AND IT IS IT.
IT'S IT'S A NEW --
ENGAGEMENT BECAUSE IT IS THE
WILD WEST TODAY.
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT THAT WE
HEARD FROM WHAT SHE DOES THIS
AND THEY DO THAT THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENTS ANYWHERE IN THIS
SPACE -- IN
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE COUNTRY --
AND SO IT WAS AT IT THAT CONTEXT
THAT I SEE THAT MY FEELING WAS
[inaudible]
I AND WE TOOK A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THIS BILL I
CAN GO THROUGH THOSE
[inaudible]
I HAVE THE FIRST STEP SHOULD BE
A SIMPLE DISCLOSURE MECHANISM --
WITH THE SUNSET.
AND THAT WE CAN EVALUATE IT AS
IT GOES I DON'T WANT TO CURTAIL
THE LENDING MARKET WHATSOEVER --
BUT IF WE HAVE BAD ACTORS THAT
CONTINUE DID NOT FOLLOW THOSE
RULES THAT I'M VERY OPEN TO
TRYING TO SEE WHAT ELSE IS WAS
REQUIRED AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE
TAKEN A SMALL STEP TODAY THAT
YOU SEE IN FRONT OF YOU.
SO YOU'RE YEAR THIS IS NOT A
MATTER OF THIS WILL BE ADDRESSED
IN A FUTURE COMMITTEE OR BEFORE
COMES TO THE FLOOR AIDS IT IS
THE INTENT TO TO LEAVE IT --
SORT OF OPEN AT LEAST AT THIS
POINT AGAIN GIVEN THAT VARIOUS
PLAYERS IN THIS IN THE IN THE
SPACE --
THAT THE SMALLER STEP TO ME
WOULD SEEM TO BE THE MORE
APPROPRIATE STEP NO IT IS NOT MY
INTENTION TO PUT A NEW
REGULATORY.
I FRAMEWORK UNDER THIS BILL I
THINK THAT MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT AND LISTEN.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE OPPOSITION
APR OF FROM THE START WE MIGHT
BE A DIFFERENT PLACE TODAY BUT I
TRY TO ACCOMMODATE.
A OPPOSITION AND THAT'S WHY YOU
HAVE THE NARROWNESS OF THIS BILL
BEFORE YOU.
I'M OKAY THANK YOU.
A SOMBER TALES ELECTRIC.
AND I'M OBVIOUSLY I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE OPPOSITION WAS TAPE PR
ALL OF THIS IS NEW TO ME AND
FAIRLY NEW TO THIS COMMITTEE BUT
I AM CONCERNED --
WITH KIND OF I DON'T SAY
UNSOPHISTICATED BUT YOU KNOW MY
FATHER HAS HAD SMALL BUSINESSES
AND HAS MADE DETERMINATIONS
WHETHER HE PUT SOMETHING ON A
CREDIT CARD VERSUS TAKES OUT
SOME SORT OF LOAN --
WHAT?
IS THE ACC ALWAYS GOING TO BE
SMALLER THAN THE A PR I I REALLY
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT THESE THINGS.
IT DEPENDS ON THE DURATION --
AT IT IT'S IT'S IT'S MEANT TO
SAY OVER TWELVE MONTHS THAT
WOULD SEE THERE'S A LOT OF LOANS
IN THIS IS PART OF THE PROBLEM
THAT SPACES I STATE YOU NEED A
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A PIZZA
OVEN REPAIR.
AND AND I I CITY LISTEN I'LL
GIVE YOU A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
COST YOU TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
THIS IS WHAT THE OPPOSITION SAID
THAT.
SMALL VISIT PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THAT TOTAL COSTS WELL IT'S
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO GET A
THOUSAND DOLLARS NOW AND YOU
HAVE TO PAY IT BACK WHEN.
WILL HE HAVE TO PAY IT BACK IN
NINETY DAYS THAT INTEREST RATE
THAT YOUR PAIN IS GONNA BE A LOT
HIGHER THAN YOU CAN THAT PAID
BACK IN A YEAR.
OR HE PAID IT BACK BASED ON
TAKING A PENNY OUT OF EVERY
CREDIT CARD TRANSACTION.
I THINK SO WHEN THESE LENDERS
COMMAND THEY CAN OFFER YOU THIS
WIDE ARRAY OF WAYS IN WHICH IT'S
NOT GONNA COST YOU ANYTHING TO
YOUR DAD.
I'M AND THAT'S BEEN THE
CHALLENGE THAT THE ISSUE OF THAT
THE ANNUALIZED COST OF CAPITAL
TO SAY WHETHER YOU TAKE THAT
LOAN FOR NINETY DAYS OR FOR TWO
YEARS.
YOU HAVE A AN ANNUALIZED COSTS
AS IF IT WAS FOR TWELVE MONTHS.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THE KNOWING
HOW MUCH IT'S GOING TO COST YOU.
YOU CAN SHOP THE NEXT VENDOR AND
THE NEXT FINANCIER AND HAVE AN
APPLES TO APPLES TO COMPARE IT
TO BECAUSE ONE VENDOR MAY SAKE
PAY ME UP PAY ME IN SIX MONTHS.
ANOTHER ONE WILL SAY WILL
EIGHTEEN MONTHS WELL WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE AND SO THAT
ANNUALIZED COST AS A WAY TO HAVE
THAT ONE STANDARD.
REVIEW WHEN WE I DID DO A CHART
HERE.
I THINK IF YOU A SENSE OF THESE
OF THE STANDARDS REQUIRED BY THE
BILL.
AND AT THE BOTTOM OF IT SAYS
WHAT'S THE ANNUALIZED COST OF
CAPITAL YOU HAVE A WAY OF
REVEALING THAT THIS.
THIS CHART IS BASED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME.
OVER THE PERIOD OF TIME AND SO
EACH OF THE STEPS.
IT'S CLOSED AND THEN THIS IS THE
LAST ONE THE BILL THAT'S BEING
DEBATED TODAY WHAT'S THAT
ANALYZE COSTS BE PAID OVER
TWELVE MONTHS.
THIS IS A FIFTEEN MONTH EXAMPLE
FOR THIS IS WHAT IT WOULD BE
OVER TWELVE AND YOU CAN A PARENT
FROM PERSON TO PERSON HURT OUR
LENDER TO LENDER IS LONG AS THE
PRODUCT YOU'RE GETTING IS ALL
FROM LIKE.
THE I THINK WHAT I'M.
STRUGGLING WITH IS YOU'RE MAKING
AN ASSUMPTION THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING JUST AT THIS ONE PRODUCT
RIGHT THIS ONLINE.
PRODUCT IN YOUR NOT THINKING
THROUGH LIKE WELL I HAVE SPACE
ON THIS CREDIT CARD I HAVE THE
ABILITY YOU KNOW IN IT FOR NOT
USING THEN THE SAME PERCENTAGE.
THEN IT'S BIAS TO THIS BECAUSE
YOU'RE GONNA GET A LOWER
PERCENTAGE THAT'S WHAT I'M
CONCERNED DOES THAT MAKE SENSE
IT SO NOW ME IF I FEEL REALLY
IGNORANT ENOUGH SPACE IDOLS I I
DON'T KNOW AND LISTEN WELCOME TO
THE WORLD OF SMALL BUSINESS
LENDING OKAY.
RIGHT WHEN WE'RE EVEN US HAVE TO
HAVE STRUGGLE WITH THAT SO THIS
IS AN EXAMPLE BASED ON A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ONE TIME LOAN
PAID OFF.
OVER A IS IT THAT THREE ABOUT
THREE YEARS AND AM.
NOW.
HERE'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
BUT NOW IT'S PAID OFF.
A LITTLE OVER A YEAR.
A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AND IT
COMES FROM UP MONEY MONEY OUT OF
YOUR SEATS IS.
AGAIN THIS IS THE FIFTEEN MONTH
LONG ONE TIME THIS IS THIS IS
MONEY OUT OF YOUR CASH REGISTER
OVER A MUCH LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME.
AND YOU CAN SEE HOW THESE CHARTS
THAT WORK OUT.
UNDER THIS ONE IT'S A HUNDRED
FIFTH THEY'RE BOTH A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS IS THE TOTAL COST OF THE
ALL YOUR PAYMENTS IS ONE SEVENTY
THAT'S ONE SEVENTY NINE HERE'S
YOUR FINANCING COSTS UNDER THIS
EXAMPLE IT'S TWENTY THOUSAND ON
THIS EXAMPLE WITH ITS.
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND HERE'S HOW
MUCH YOU PAID EVERY DAY IF
WHAT'S MOST SENSITIVE YOUR DAD
WAS HOW MUCH HE HAD TO PUT OUT
EVERY DAY.
THIS ONE IT'S RETURN SEVENTY
DOLLARS THAT ONE IS A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE DOLLARS.
AND SO YOU WORK DOWN THIS CHART
AND THEN YOU SAY WELL WHAT IF I
HAD TO PAY THIS OVER ONE YEAR
THE APPLES AND APPLES.
THIS IS A 10% COST AND THAT ONCE
THE 6% COST BUT YOU GET A SENSE
OF THE COMPLEXITY OF THESE JUST
TWO DIFFERENT EXAMPLES OF FLAT
LOAN.
VERSUS SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
GONNA PAY OFF EVERY DAY I'VE
YOUR CASH REGISTER.
AND THIS IS THE DILEMMA THAT
THEY ALL FACE HOW DO YOU CREATE
THE APPLES TO APPLES WITH THESE
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS.
AND THIS SHOWS YOU THAT YOU CAN
HAVE DIFFERENT PRODUCTS.
WITH DIFFERENT LOAN AMOUNTS IN
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS BUT THE ONE
THING THAT YOU CAN COMPARE THE
APPLES.
TO IS THE ANNUALIZED COST OF
CAPITAL IN BOTH BOTH CHARTS.
THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO GET YOU
AN APR AN ACC.
THE GOING TO SHOW YOU THE A
WHATEVER THE LAW REQUIRES WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO PROVIDE IN THIS
IS A WAY FEET ACROSS COMPARISON
SHOP THAT DOES EXIST TODAY
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SOME SORRY.
SO I GET HOW YOU CAN COMPARE THE
EAST.
TALL IN I I APPLAUD WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO I THINK THIS IS
GOOD.
MY CONCERN IS HOW DO YOU COMPARE
THIS -- TO
MY A BUSINESS CREDIT CARD OR
SOMETHING IT'S GIVING ME JUST
ANY PR.
AT THE CAN.
SMALL BUSINESSES USE
[inaudible]
CREDIT.
VARIETY OF WAYS A MINUTE I GUESS
YOU CAN SAY LOAN BUT I MEAN
ESPECIALLY SMALL BUSINESSES.
USE OF RIGHT I'M JUST WORRIED
ABOUT THAT LIKE ARE WE THIS
MAKES VERY GOOD.
FOR WHAT WERE WHAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO DO BUT THAT'S NOT THE
ONLY WAY PEOPLE AYE AYE BORROW
MONEY TO WRITE AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT THAT THE CREDIT
CARD APR IT'S BASED ON HOW MUCH
YOU PAY AND WHEN THAT WOULD
THAT'S JUST AN ESTIMATE.
BUT IT'S A CHANGING ESTIMATE
EVERY MONTH IF YOU DECIDE TO
ONLY PAY SO MUCH INTO PRINCIPLE.
AT THAT'S GONNA CHANGE.
THAT NUMBER AND SO THAT'S THE
DILEMMA OF EVEN LOOKING AT THAT
FINANCIAL INSTRUMENT OF COUPLE
OF I PUT THIS ON MY CREDIT CARD.
VERSES TAKE GOTTA A A A BUSINESS
LOAN IT'S A VERY CHALLENGING
THING FOR ANYONE TO TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE A AND AND
THAT'S WHY TO GO BACK TO THE
SIMPLICITY IS THE ANNUAL COST.
NOT AN AP ARE THAT THAT
FLUCTUATES AND OBVIOUSLY SOME IN
THE INDUSTRY SAY WE LOVE ITAND
SOME SAY THEY HATE IT.
AND WANTED IT CHANGED IN THE
BILL.
AND THAT WILL ALWAYS REMAIN THAT
DILEMMA BUYER BEWARE WITH BUYER
BEWARE LENDER BE WHERE.
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO GIVE THAT
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER ONE
ADDITIONAL TOOL AND THAT'S NOT
HOW MUCH IS THE MONEY GOING TO
COST ME OR HOW MUCH I PAY EVERY
DAY WHAT WITH THIS COSTA BY
HEADED FOR TWELVE MONTHS WHY
WOULDN'T YOU HAVE BALLS.
WHAT WILL WE DO THE BILL DOES
REQUIRED THAT --
THAT ALL THESE ELEMENTS NOT BE
PROVIDED NO APR AN ACC WHY
WOULDN'T YOU HAVE BOTH.
WELL FIRST WE HAD THE CONCERN OF
ON A P. R. ABOUT THE LEGAL
JEOPARDY OF THAT NUMBER
FLUCTUATING AND HOW CAN YOU HAVE
IT BE A FAIR ESTIMATE.
HOW DO THEY DO IT ON CREDIT
CARDS I GET A CREDIT CARDS ARE
I'M APPLYING FOR CREDIT CARD AND
TELLS ME?
THIS IS THE A PR AND THAT'S OUR
IS ABOUT A STACK OF FEDERAL
REGULATION THIS HIGH THAT WENT
INTO.
HI THAT HIGH PLUS MORE THAT GOT
INTO THE WHOLE --
DETERMINATION OF A PR I AND WHEN
YOU SAY IT'S IT YOU KNOW IT IT'S
BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME IT'S
BEEN HOTLY DEBATED.
ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND SO YOU
HAVE THIS BODY OF OF INFORMATION
THAT'S NOW THERE THAT GUIDES
COMPANIES AND HOW THEY HOW THEY
DO AND HOW THEY CALCULATED.
LET'S THESE COMPANIES COULD DO
THAT.
THEY COULD DO THAT TODAY AND
MOST OF THEM DON'T --
I'M HAPPY HERE ONE THAT DOES
PROVIDE IT BUT THE IT AGAIN IT'S
THE WILD WEST OF SO WHY WOULDN'T
WE WANT PEOPLE.
I'M JUST I'M STILL BESIDES.
I AM HAVING THERE'S A FUNCTION
TO DO IT AND THEN THAT IT COULD
BETTER CROSS COMPARE BETWEEN
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS Y..
MEN'S MORE DISCLOSURE NOT LAUGHS
YES SO WHY A I I I IN AYE I'M
NOT LIKE SITTING NO I DON'T I
HAVE NO IDEA I'M I'M TOTALLY
CONFUSED ON TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING IN THIS BILL SO.
YEAH WILL LOOK AT I'M OPEN
MINDED THAT FOR ME THE ISSUE THE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE IS.
HOW DO WE PROVIDE AN APPROPRIATE
LEVEL DISCLOSURE TO GET THAT
SMALL BUSINESS PERSON A FIGHTING
CHANCE?
IN THE LENDING MARKET I HADN'T
THOUGHT ABOUT WHETHER A
PROVIDING BOTH AND WHETHER THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL ARE LESS
HELPFUL I'M OPEN MINDED TO IT.
IT WAS REALLY TRYING TO I'VE
BEEN TRYING TO SIMPLIFY THIS
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
EFFORTS TO COMPLICATED AND
THAT'S WHY HADN'T GONE IN THAT
DIRECTION BUT I'M STILL OPEN
MINDED ABOUT WHETHER THAT WE
HAVE MORE HELP FULLER LESS.
WHY WOULD SAY FOR A LOT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES AND I THINK ABOUT
SMALL BUSINESSES MY COMMUNITY
WHERE YOU HAVE A LOT OF NON
ENGLISH SPEAKERS A LOT NOT
NATIVE SPEAKERS?
BEING ABLE TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT
TWO DIFFERENT COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS ONE THAT'S
NOT MAYBE NOT SUPPOSE WE USE FOR
SMALL BUSINESS LOANS BUT AS A
CREDIT CARD VERSES THIS.
THAT TO WIND UP THE LETTERS
REGARDLESS OF HOW YOU GET TO
THAT NUMBER WHAT IT MEANS THEN
BUT WHY NOT THE LETTERS AND TRY
TO GET TO SOME.
COMPARISON WOULD BE HELPFUL
ASSUMING THE LEVEL OF KNOWLEDGE
I THINK THAT.
THAT EVEN IF IT WAS IN THERE --
HOME LANGUAGE.
PROBABLY I MEAN IT'S BEYOND ME
AND SIR MYSELF SLIGHTLY EDUCATED
BUT I DEFINITELY WITH FOLKS WHO
WHO ARE NEW TO THIS COUNTRY AND
WHO ARE TRYING TO FIGURE THIS
ALL OUT A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
[inaudible]
THINK.
THINK YOU AS A MEMBER STEINORTH --
FIRST I'D JUST LIKE TO SAY I
THINK THIS IS VERY CLEVER --
I'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS AND MY BUSINESS IS
HELPING LOCAL AND SMALL
BUSINESSES GROW AND I'VE BEEN
DOING THAT SUCCESSFULLY I'VE
PROBABLY HELPED OVER TEN
THOUSAND BUSINESSES BE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND TO THE SINGLE GREATEST
REASON FOR THEIR FAILURE IS
UNDER CAPITALIZATION.
PERIOD THAT'S IT AND SO SHORT
TERM VERSUS LONGER TERM --
ACCESS TO CAPITAL I BELIEVE THAT
YOUR WAY OF I'M REALLY TRYING TO
ADD TO TRANSPARENCY TO THE SHORT
TERM ACCESS TO CAPITAL SO PEOPLE
HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT IT'S GOING TO COST A
BUSINESS.
SKIN BE VERY USEFUL FOR THEIR
SUCCESS SO I'LL BE VOTING YES ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
A SENATOR YOU KNOW I'VE HAD
MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS AYE ANYTHING AND THE
ANALYSIS DOES EXPRESS SOME
CONCERN --
WITH THE ABILITY --
TO IN FORCE PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
ENFORCEMENT IS ALSO A WAY.
TO ENSURE THAT YOUR OBJECTIVE IS
MET.
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE
OBJECTIVE [inaudible]
AND BUT WE'VE ALSO HAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
DIRECTION OF THE BILL.
AND KNOWING HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
I'VE [inaudible]
FOR ANY.
YOU NO CONSUMER BUT TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO MAKE
THE BEST DECISIONS.
WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT AT THIS
POINT ON?
APR YU'RE LUCKY IF YOU HAVE IT.
AND SOME DO SOME DON'T IT'S NOT
A STANDARDIZATION AND SO AS I
LISTEN TO COLLEAGUES BRING ON
THE CONCERNS FORWARD ABOUT HOW
DO YOU COMPARE.
ALL OF YOUR OPTIONS NOT JUST
YOUR ONLINE LENDING BUT ALL OF
YOUR OPTIONS AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT CURRENTLY THAT
CAN EXIST BECAUSE IF THEY RIGHT
NOW TWO DAY IF THEY WERE TO TRY
TO GO TO AN ONLINE LOAN.
I'M OR A CASH ADVANCE I AND ALSO
COMPARE CREDIT CARDS THEY DON'T
HAVE THE MECHANISM TO TO TO LOOK
AT IT.
AN APPLES TO APPLES I APPRECIATE
THAT THIS IS THAT AT LEAST FOR
THE MOMENT A TEMPORARY SOLUTION
HAS A FOUR YEAR SUNSET SO THAT
WE CAN UNDERSTAND.
I AM I STILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THE OBJECTIVE
IS GOING TO BE MET HOW WE KNOW
THAT WHETHER IT'S ACC YOU'RE
SOMETHING ELSE.
IS GOING TO BE MATT AND AND HOW
WE'RE ENSURING THAT OVER THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS AT POTENTIALLY
ALL THE CONSUMERS AND OUR
CUSTOMERS OF THIS PRODUCT I SEE
THE SAME THING I'M NOT SURE.
UP BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN THEMES
ON THAT YOU HAVE BROUGHT FORWARD.
THEMES THAT I HAVE THE SENSITIVE
TO THIS YEAR IN THE WORLD OF
BANKING AND FINANCE AND THOSE
INCLUDE THE IMPORTANCE FOR
TRANSPARENCY.
A FOR DISCLOSURE.
AND FOR PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
TRUE COST OF THE LOAN.
I UNDERSTAND HOW HARD IT IS FOR
THESE THINGS.
UP ARE THESE ELEMENTS TO BE IN
PLACE WITH A LOT OF PRODUCTS.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I I AM
GOING TO GIVE YOU AN AYE VOTE IN
AND IN GOOD FAITH --
AT THAT.
WE CAN TRY TO GET THRE ON BUT I
WILL NOTE THAT THERE ARE STILL
SOME CONCERNS AND I'M HAPPY TO
BE PART OF ANY KIND OF
CONVERSATION TO REACH.
UP TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
OBJECTIVE YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
TO IS ONE AND THAT IS ABLE TO BE
MET -- AND I
KNOW HOW HARD THIS WORK IS A AND
UP WITH THAT IF THERE ARE NO
OTHER COMMENTS I THINK
[inaudible]
WE WILL.
I HAVE YOU CLOSE AND THEN WILL
TAKE ABOUT.
YEAH I THINK YOU BETTER AND
SHARON MEMBERS FOR THIS
THOUGHTFUL AT A THOROUGH
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD TODAY
APPRECIATE IT.
I WANT TO UNDERSCORE AGAIN HOW
HARD WE HAVE WORKED MY STAFF
THAT YOUR STAFF AND OTHERS TO
TRY.
TO NARROW THE DIFFERENCES TAKE
OUT LEASING TAKE OUT.
AT SOME OF THE RECEIVABLES
ISSUES THAT WE CAN'T REALLY FIT
INTO THIS BOX SO THAT WE COULD
PROVIDE SOMETHING THAT SIMPLE IN
AN EASY AND UNDERSTANDABLE AND
TRANSPARENT.
I THINK WE'VE GOT A LONG WAYS
HERE I KNOW THERE'S MORE WORK
STILL TO BE DONE AND I'M HAPPY
TO LOOK I LOOK FOR TO THAT WORK.
THAT WE CAN DO TOGETHER WE DO
NEED TO PROTECT OUR SMALL
BUSINESS.
AND IT IS ALL WILD WEST OF
FINANCING OUT THERE AND I THINK
THIS BILL DOES GET US CLOSER TO
THAT SPACE AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
IT'S CULTURAL.
THEY WANT AYE LIMON AYE CHEN
[inaudible]
CHEN I COSTA [inaudible]
I BURKE [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
CABLE I GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NOT VOTING
GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE [inaudible]
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE STONE [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I ALRIGHT THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AND AND THAT IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO WE WILL LEAVE THE OF
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL ADD ONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU UP.
OR IF.
SENATOR ROTH.
AND THAT S. B. [inaudible]
TEN EIGHTY SEVEN GO [inaudible]
SOURCES RIGHT
.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THAT'S ABOUT HAVE AGAIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT OF THE SENATE BILL.
TEN EIGHTY SEVEN AS YOU WELL
KNOW PACE IS AN IMPORTANT THAT'S
THE PROPERTY ASSESSED CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAM IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM IN OUR STATE IT'S
ACCOMPLISHED A GREAT DEAL OF
GOOD HAS THE POTENTIAL.
TO ACCOMPLISH A LOT MORE THE
MEASURE BEFORE YOU PROPOSES SOME
WHAT WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT
CLEAN UP PROVISIONS TO LAST
YEAR'S.
A PACE MEASURES.
I'LL HIGHLIGHT THREE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ONES FOR YOU FIRST THE
BILL PROHIBITS HOME IMPROVEMENT
CONTRACTORS FROM COMMENCING HOME
IMPROVEMENT CONTRACTS.
AND MAKE THOSE CONTRACTS
UNENFORCEABLE IF.
THE PROPERTY OWNER ENTERS INTO
HOME IMPROVEMENT CONTRACT BASED
ON THE REASONABLE BELIEF THAT
THE WORK WILL BE COVERED BY PACE.
AND APPLIES FOR BUT IS NOT
APPROVED FOR PACE FINANCING IN
THE AMOUNT REQUESTED BY THE
PROPERTY OWNER IN OTHER WORDS
THERE'S A DISCREPANCY BETWEEN
THE HOME IMPROVEMENT CONTRACT
PRICE.
AND THE AMOUNT OF PAYS FINANCING
APPROVED SECOND THE BILL
INSURERS TRANSPARENCY REGARDING
PLAYSPACE SOLICITORS AND PAY
SOLICITOR AGENTS.
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT.
IT GIVES THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TOOLS A TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THIRD THE BILL
GIVES DB ó.
THE ABILITY TO STEP IN AND TAKE
IMMEDIATE DISCIPLINARY ACTION.
IF TVO LEARNS TO PAY SOLICITOR
OR SOLICITOR AGENT AND SELLING
PAYS FINANCING IN A MANNER.
THAT HARMS HOMEOWNERS THEN
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE BILL
DOES IN ITS MOST IMPORTANT
CONCEPTS IN A WITH THAT I'D AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME REQUEST.
A RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
DON'T THINK YOU SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NIKKI MORE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT LIKE TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR HIS EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS TRANSPARENCY WITH
RESPECT TO MISCONDUCT.
MIST -- IF A
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRES
DISCLOSURES IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT TAKES
CORRECTIVE ACTION.
AND THAT THOSE ACTIONS WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO DISCLOSURE THAT
ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO OUGHT TO
KNOW IF THERE COMMUNITY HAS A
BAD ACTOR AYE AND IF THERE LOANS
WERE I'M SUBJECT.
TO WERE CONTROLLED BY THAT AGENT
SO -- FOR
THE TRANSPARENCY MEASURES WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY FRIEND I'VE
OF NOW MY FRIEND THAT'S KEY WITH
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD OR CSO BE FOR SHORT.
ADD CSW IN SUPPORT OF TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BECAUSE IT INCREASES
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE SOLICITED
INTO PASTE ASSESSMENT CONTRACTS
BY PACE LISTENERS AND PACE WITH
HER AGENTS.
HARM SOLICITOR INFLICTING AGENTS
WILL PRIMARILY BE C. SLB
LICENTIATE.
ARM UNDER CURRENT LOS YES WILL
BE IS LIMITED BAVIER.
THAT PACE --
APACE LOAN AYE ABSENT A CLEAR
CASE OF MISREPRESENTATION OR
FRAUD AYE WE BELIEVE THAT'S
BECOME A SEVEN GOES A LONG WAY
WITH THE UNDERWRITING
REQUIREMENTS AND THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TOWARDS PROTECTIONS
IN THE PACE INDUSTRY.
THANKS SO MUCH.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HIS NAME AFFILIATION PLEASE
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS COURTNEY
JOHNSON OF THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND A BUCK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIGHT
BELOW FOR THE CALIFORNIA SCREW
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE
ASSOCIATION AND UNITED TRUSTEES
ASSOCIATION WE BELIEVE THE BILL
STRIKES A FAIR BALANCE WE
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PAT'S ANGELA WITH KEY PEOPLE
BOOK AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION WHO ALSO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS KEVIN
GOULD WITH CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I THINK I CAN ALMOST SAY GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M.
PASSING GILSON ON BEHALF OF
RENOVATE AMERICA I'M
RESPECTFULLY UNOPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION I WANT TO START
WITH A TREMENDOUS THANKS TO THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF. FOR THE
EARLY OUTREACH AND REALLY
DILIGENCE IN WORKING WITH US AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS THREE THESE
ISSUES --
MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT THIS WILL
BE I THINK THE FOURTH BILL IN
TWO AND A HALF YEARS THAT WE'VE
DONE ON PACE.
AND THAT INCLUDES A BILL FROM
LAST YEAR THAT SET UP THE
DEPARTMENT OF OVERSIGHT AS THE
STATEWIDE REGULATOR.
AND THEY ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING COMPREHENSIVE
REGULATIONS OVER THE PACE
INDUSTRY SO YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
WHY I'M WE HAVE SOME CAUTION
WITH ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION
WHILE THAT IS ONGOING.
I'M I THINK WE'VE MADE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PROGRESS UP
PROGRESS THIS IS A SITUATION
WHERE THAT THE DETAILS REALLY
MATTER.
I'M AND SO WERE I'M OPTIMISTIC
THAT IF WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE SENATOR THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
AND EFFECTIVELY THREAD THE
NEEDLE TO MAKE SURE THAT PACE
COULD CONTINUE TO PROVIDE.
THE INVALUABLE TOOL THAT IT DOES
TO ADDRESS THE INEFFICIENCY OF
OUR EXISTING BUILDINGS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAROLINE BEALE HUNTER HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF WHITE GREEN ENERGY FUN
AND WE TO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
HAS THE TIME HE'S TAKEN
PERSONALLY TO WORK WITH US AND
HIS STAFF ON WORKING ON OUR
CONCERNS.
ON WE FEEL CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH
THE LAST FEW ON ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE BUT FOR THE TIME BEING WE
REMAIN OPPOSED LESS AMENDED BUT
ARE CONFIDENT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE.
TO GET TO THOSE LAST ISSUES THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE STATE YOUR IT
AT NAME POSITION ASSOCIATION
JENNIFER SIDE ARMY HAVE TO RENEW
FINANCIAL THEM WOULD REFLECT THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN SAID
EARLIER INTERESTED IN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR THINKING.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF ADVANCE
ENERGY ECONOMY.
WE ALSO HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION IN LINE WITH
PREVIOUS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION SEEN NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
THIS FORWARD AND FOR WORKING.
SO WELL WITH THAT AT OPPOSITION
HE HAS BEEN A LONG CONVERSATION.
LONG CONVERSATION IN PROCESS I
KNOW IT'S BEEN NOTED THAT THIS
IS -- ONE OF
MULTIPLE BILLS THAT'S COME
FORWARD IN RECENT YEARS AND I
HOPE THAT THAT SEEMED POSITIVE
ENERGY OF A GETTING TO A PLACE
IS THE ENERGY THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE.
ON AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD AT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
LIMON I LIMON AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BURKE. SEVEN SORRY
GLORIA [inaudible]
LAURIE HI [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
DISSOLVES FLETCHER AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON HIGH STEINORTH
[inaudible]
STEINORTH I STONE [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I IRATE THE BILL IS THAT
EACH WILL LEAVE IT OPEN AND FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON A MOVES
OVER TO APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION HE SENATOR
[inaudible]
COULD.
WILL GO AHEAD AND DO WHAT WE
WILL HEAR --
SP EIGHT TWENTY SIX AND THANK
YOU CENTER JACKSON FOR JOINING
US WILL COULD THE ALMOST EVENING.
A AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A SBA
TWENTY SIX I REALLY LIKE THIS
BILL I HAVE TO SAY YOU KNOW WE
ALL.
WE BROUGH BRING A LOT OF BILLS
AND SUMMER KIND OF MORE EXCITING
THAN OTHERS AND I THINK THIS IS
A WONDERFUL BILL IT IS A
PROACTIVE.
APPROACH TO REQUIRE MORE WOMEN
DIRECTORS ON THE BOARDS OF
PUBLICLY HELD CORPORATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS S. B. A
TWENTY SIX CALIFORNIA WOMEN.
MAKE UP 52% OF THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA BUT ONLY ABOUT
FIFTEEN AND A HALF PERCENT OF
THE DIRECTORS OF OUR PUBLIC
CORPORATIONS.
I LOOK AT THE WOMEN AT THE
STYLUS AND I KNOW THAT EACH ONE
OF YOU.
IS QUALIFIED TO SERVE IN THAT
CAPACITY AS WELL AS THE CAPACITY
HERE AS A MEMBER OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
AND THAT INCLUDES NONPROFIT
BOARDS AS WELL.
SO MORE THAN 80% OF THE STATE'S
CORPORATIONS ARE OPERATING
WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF THE
EXPERIENCE PERSPECTIVE AND TOOLS
THAT WOMEN BRING WITH THEM TO
THE CORPORATE SETTING.
AND THE LIFE EXPERIENCE THAT
WOMEN HAVE THAT ENHANCE.
THE RESULTS OF CORPORATIONS
BECAUSE RESEARCH CLEARLY SHOWS
THAT BOARDS WITH WOMEN MEMBERS
PERFORM BETTER IN THE
MARKETPLACE.
BY HAVING SUCH LOW PARTICIPATION
RATES FOR WOMEN IN ARE KEPT OUR
CORPORATE LEADERSHIP RANKS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE EFFECTIVELY
INHIBIT OUR OWN ECONOMIC
PERFORMANCE IS A STATE.
OTHER NATIONS HAVE PREVIOUSLY
ACKNOWLEDGED THE FINANCIAL
BENEFITS AND ACTUALLY REQUIRE A
PERCENTAGE OF BOARD MEMBERS TO
BE FEMALE THAT'S REPRESENTING
THE EXPERIENCE EXPERTISE AND
WISDOM OF HALF THE POPULATION.
WHICH ALSO REPRESENTS 70% OF ALL
THE CONSUMERS.
THIS MEASURE TAKES A BIG STEP
TOWARD CLOSING THIS GENDER GAP.
IT INCREASES GENDER DIVERSITY ON
CORPORATE BOARDS BY REQUIRING
EACH PUBLICLY HELD CORPORATION
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO HAVE AT LEAST ONE WOMAN ON
ITS BOARD OF DIRECTORS BY THE
END OF TWENTY NINETEEN AND
BEGINNING IN JULY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE BILL WILL
REQUIRE A MINIMUM OF TWO WOMEN
DIRECTORS ON BOARDS WHERE THERE
ARE FIVE DIRECTORS AND AT LEAST
THREE WOMEN ON BOARDS WHERE
THERE ARE SIX OR MORE DIRECTORS.
AND AS I MENTIONED THE RESEARCH
ON THIS IS CLEAR.
THOSE ARE TWENTY SIXTEEN
MACKENZIE SURE CONSULTING FIRM A
BUSINESS CONSULTING FIRM VERY
HIGHLY REGARDED THE DID A STUDY
REVEALED THAT NATIONWIDE THE
COMPANIES WHERE WOMEN ARE MOST
STRONGLY REPRESENTED AT BORDER
TOP MANAGEMENT LEVELS.
ARE ALSO BUSINESSES THAT
PERFORMED THE BEST.
IN PROFITABILITY PRODUCTIVITY
INNOVATION GOVERNANCE BETTER
PERFORMANCE AND WORKFORCE
ENGAGEMENT.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU ASK?
SO -- THIS A
STUDY ALSO FOUND THAT IN
COMPANIES WHERE THERE WERE THREE
OR MORE WOMEN CREATING SORT OF
THAT CRITICAL MASS THAT WE TALK
ABOUT.
SENIOR MANAGEMENT ABOUT WHAT
WERE THEY THREE MORE WOMEN IN
SENIOR MANAGEMENT POSITIONS THEY
SCORED HIGHER ON AVERAGE ON THE
ORGANIZATION PERFORMANCE PROFILE.
THAN COMPANIES WITH NO WOMEN ON
BOARDS OR IN THE EXECUTIVE RANKS
WOMEN MAKE BUSINESSES MORE
PROFITABLE MORE PRODUCTIVE AND
BETTER.
SO I AUTHORED A RESOLUTION ON
THIS IN TWENTY THIRTEEN SCR A
SIXTY TWO THAT URGED.
URGED OUR BOARDS AND A THE
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES THAT --
ARE PUBLICLY TRADED TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF WOMEN ON THEIR
BOARDS TWO ONE TWO AND THREE
DEPENDING UPON THE SIZE OF THE
BOARDS IT WE IT WAS A PRETTY
PLEASE.
BUT THE PRETTY PLEASED AND GET
US ANYWHERE BECAUSE IT THAT THE
THERE WAS NO UPTICK WHATSOEVER
AS A RESULT OF THAT.
AND CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST
STATE IN THE UNITED STATES TO
ADOPT THIS TYPE OF RESOLUTION
WHICH WAS AGAIN OVERWHELMINGLY
SUPPORTED.
BUT AND FIVE OTHER STATES HAVE
PASSED SIMILAR MEASURES BUT BY
THE END OF TWENTY SIXTEEN FEWER
THAN 20%.
OF THE RUSSELL THREE THOUSAND
COMPANIES ARE HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA HAD THE MINIMUM
NUMBER OF WOMEN DIRECTORS CALLED
FOR IN THE RESOLUTION.
WE'VE GOT.
TO BASICALLY MOVE THAT ENVELOPE
MOVE THAT TICK UPWARD
SIGNIFICANTLY FOR THE BETTERMENT
OF OUR CORPORATE --
STRUCTURE OF FOR THE BETTERMENT
OF PEOPLE WORKING THESE
COMPANIES AND I WOULD SUBMIT TO
YOU.
IF IN THE MIRAMAX COMPANY OR THE
WEINSTEIN COMPANY AS IT BECAME
IF THERE HAD BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF WOMEN ON THAT BOARD
HARVEY WEINSTEIN WOULD NOT HAVE
GOTTEN AWAY WITH THE KIND OF
BEHAVIOR HE WAS ABLE TO GET AWAY
WITH --
CONDONED BY THAT BOARD FOR AS
MANY YEARS AS HE DID WOMEN ADD
VALUE.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD TO A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE I HAVE JOINING ME TODAY.
ANNA LISA PARA TWO IS A CLINICAL
PROFESSOR OF FINANCE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF BUSINESS.
SHE TEACHES GRADUATE COURSES IN
CORPORATE GOVERNANCE AND
UNDERGRADUATE COURSES IN
FINANCIAL STATEMENT ANALYSIS
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT AND
PERSONAL FINANCE.
AND MY GOOD FRIEND BETSY BURKE
KOMMER HRIDAYA WHO IS THE CEO OF
BURKE FROM A BURKE AMER CLAYTON
RETAINED EXECUTIVE SEARCH
COMPANY IN LOS ANGELES.
AND CEO OF THE NATIONAL. TWENTY
TWENTY WOMEN ON BOARDS A
RESEARCH AND PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN TO ACHIEVE 20% A PUBLIC
COMPANY BOARD SEATS HELD BY
WOMEN OF ALL ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS.
BY A BY THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
SHE'S ALSO THE AUTHOR OF THE
BOOK THE BOARD GAME AND PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
NOVEL -- IN
WITH ME HERE TODAY TO SPEAK AT
THAT --
LADIES THANK YOU RIGHT THANK YOU
AND I WILL ASK FOR BREVITY AND
JUST AS WE ARE AT IN THE EVENING
PORTIONS OF OUR DAY SO THANK YOU.
WE BROUGHT A LITTLE PARTY FAVORS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT COULD MAKE
IT MORE HER.
MACON AFTERNOON EVENING OF IT
I'M BETSY BURKE AMER CRITTER
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR ALL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE ON THIS
REMARKABLE BILL.
AND I'M HERE TO EXPLAIN BRIEFLY
OF WHAT HAPPENS IN --
EXECUTIVE SEARCH I'VE OWNED IT
EXECUTIVE SEARCH FIRM FOR TWENTY
FOUR YEARS AND OF HANDLED MANY
BOARD SEARCHES AND TO EXPLAIN
WHY THERE ARE NOT MORE WOMEN ON
BOARD CURRENTLY WHY DOESN'T THIS
JUST HAPPEN ORGANICALLY.
AND IT'S BECAUSE OVER THE YEARS
OF MEN UNDERSTANDABLY SO --
OVER THE YEARS DECADES OF
COMPANIES OF OUR CEOS HAVE
WANTED OTHER CEOS TO BE ON THEIR
ADVISORY BOARDS ON THEIR BOARDS
OF DIRECTORS TO ADVISE THEM HOW
TO BE A CEO AND THAT'S WHAT THE
BOARD DOES.
IS TO HIRE AND FIRE THE C. E. O.
ADVISE THE STRATEGY OF THE
COMPANY AND TO GUIDE THE
COMPENSATION OF THE CEO AND THE
SENIOR MANAGEMENT.
SO TRADITIONALLY OF THEY'VE ALL.
MEMBERS AND THAT PRIMARILY IS
ANGLO MEANT.
AND WITH THAT O. WHEN THE IT HAS
EVOLVED THAT --
MORE SHAREHOLDERS ARE INSISTING
THAT OTHER TALENTS BE BROUGHT ON
OTHER EXPERIENCE AT A IN NOW ON
BOARD ROOMS BECAUSE OF SO MANY
OTHER --
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT COMPANIES
HAVE TO FACE ON BEHALF OF THE
SHAREHOLDERS LIKE A
CYBERSECURITY AND HUMAN
RESOURCES AND THE OTHER ASPECTS
OF THE TECHNOLOGY IT'S SET FOR
OF THAT WOMEN CAN BRING TO THE
BOARD.
NOW THERE'S A POSSIBILITY THAT
THEY WOULD CONSIDER WOMEN
HOWEVER WHEN BOARD MEMBERS THAT
WHEN THE BOARD HIRE US TO DO A
SEARCH THEY SAY BETSY BRING US A
WOMAN.
WITH A REALLY ONE A WOMAN BUT
WILL GOTTA HAVE ONE BECAUSE THE
SHAREHOLDERS WHAT WHAT AND I
I'VE HEARD THIS.
AND WE JUST LAUGHED AT THAT A
LITTLE BIT AND THEN CONTINUE ON
BUT SEARCH BUT THEY SAY OF BRING
US ONE WHO DOESN'T TALK TOO MUCH
AND DOESN'T DISRUPT TOO MUCH.
SO THERE'S AN AUTOMATIC FEELING
THAT WOMEN ARE A BRING --
THE IT'S IT'S AND IT'S NOT MEANT
TO BE A EVIDENT BIAS BUT IT'S A
INHERENT BIAS THAT WOMEN CHANGES
THE DYNAMIC OF THE BOARD.
SO IT'S CHALLENGING TO AT LEAST
TO HAVE WOMEN WHO.
A CAN BE BOARD MEMBERS FROM THE
BOARD MEMBERS WILL ACCEPT
[inaudible]
SO.
BUT WITH MUCH MORE EFFORT TO GET
THAT DONE WE CAN MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME BY REQUIRING.
THAT EACH PUBLIC COMPANY BOARD
PUT ON AT LEAST ONE WOMAN IN THE
NEXT YEAR.
AND THEY'RE ONE FOURTH OF ALL
PUBLIC COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE NO WOMEN ON THEIR BOARDS
ONE FOURTH WHICH IS SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER AND BEEN FAR OUT WEIGH US
IN TERMS OF NUMBERS.
THAT THEY'RE THREE THREE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED MEN ON
CORPORATE BOARDS IN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC COMPANIES COMPARED TO
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE WOMEN.
SO THERE'S A HUGE DISPARITY AND
WHEN THOSE MEN ARE ASKED WHAT
WOMEN YOU KNOW OUR WAY TO GET
WHAT WOMEN YOU KNOW WHO COULD
COME ONTO OUR BOARD.
OF THEY DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
WOULD CAN ASSURE YOU THERE ARE
FIFTY EIGHT STORIES OF WOMEN IN
THIS BOOK OF MY BOOK YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BUY IT HOWEVER.
HER HIT BUT IT TALKS ABOUT HOW
THE WOMEN ONLY GOT ON TO
CORPORATE BOARDS BECAUSE THEY
KNEW SOMEONE ON THAT BOARD AND
WERE ENDORSED FOR MEMBERSHIP ON
THAT BOARD AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO GET WOMEN KNOWN.
SO WITH THAT I'LL TURN OVER THE
MICROPHONE TO AND LISA BARRETT
TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT BRIEFLY
ABOUT OUR OUR RESEARCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT THE END
THANK YOU SENATOR.
AND MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US TODAY.
MY NAME DALY SAID THERE IT AND
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED I'M A
CLINICAL PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO.
HOUSE SO CONDUCT RESEARCH ON
BOARD OF DIRECT WORDS OF
DIRECTORS AND I'VE BEEN WORKING
IN THIS FIELD ADVISING BOARDS
AND INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS.
ONBOARD EFFECTIVENESS AND BOARD
COMPOSITION FOR TWENTY YEARS.
AND I DID A STUDY LOOKING OUT
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD MEMBERS THE
CALIFORNIA BOARDS TO IDENTIFY
EXACTLY WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THE PREVALENCE OF WOMEN IN
COMPANIES HEADQUARTERED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND HAS BEEN NOTED THAT I'M
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA --
IS ACTUALLY EVEN BEHIND THE
NATIONAL PERCENTAGES WHEN IT
COMES TO PREVALENCE OF WOMEN
DIRECTORS AMONG.
AND THE PEOPLE SERVING ON
CORPORATE BOARDS OF COMPANIES
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE A LITTLE OVER 15%.
WHEREAS AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL AT
16% ON AND AS WAS MENTIONED A
QUARTER OF THE COMPANIES
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
HAD NO WOMEN ON THEIR BOARDS AND
IN FACT WHEN LOOKING AT THAT BY
REGION WE SEE UNFORTUNATELY THAT
MY HOMETOWN OF SAN DIEGO.
IS AND IS THE WORST TO HIT WHEN
IT COMES TO AND THE PREVALENCE
OF COMPANIES WITH NO FEMALE
DIRECTORS 40% OF THE COMPANIES
HEADQUARTERED IN.
SAN DIEGO HAD NO WOMEN ON THE
BOARDS.
SO -- I JUST
WANTED TO YOU KNOW TWO THINGS
BRIEFLY PLEASE AND ONE IS AT THE
ISSUES REGARDING THAT THE
AVAILABILITY OF QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES FOR BOARD SERVICE.
THERE ARE --
THERE MAY BE CONCERNS THAT THERE
ARE.
SERVE ON CORPORATE BOARDS AND IN
FACT THIS IS NOT THE CASE.
AND BETSY IS THE CEO OF
ORGANIZATION AND THERE ARE MANY
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THEN FACT AROUND THE
WORLD.
THAT AND HAVE MEMBERS WHO ARE
AND SEEKING CORPORATE BOARDS
SERVICE AND WOMEN DIRECTORS I AM.
CURRENTLY SITTING ON CORPORATE
BOARDS AND THOSE WHO ARE LOOKING
TO SERVE ON CORPORATE BOARDS WHO
ARE EMINENTLY QUALIFIED TO DO SO.
AND THERE ARE CONCERNS ALSO
ABOUT AND INDIVIDUAL WOMEN
SERVING ON TOO MANY BOARDS AND
IF THIS LAW WERE TO BE PASSED IN
FACT I JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT.
THE FACT THAT THERE IS A
MECHANISM TO ADDRESS THIS
CONCERN THAT IS IN PLACE ALREADY.
AND THERE MAY BE CONCERNED ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL SERVING ON TOO MANY
BOARDS HOWEVER THE INSTITUTIONAL
SHAREHOLDERS VOTE AGAINST
DIRECTORS WHO ARE SERVING ON TOO
MANY BOARDS.
SO BOARDS WOULD NOT ALLOW THEIR
MEMBERS TO SERVE ON MORE THAN
THREE OR FOUR CORPORATE BOARD SO
THIS WOULD NOT BE AN ISSUE FOR
THE WOMEN WHO ARE BROUGHT IN TO
SERVE ON BOARDS HEARING
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHEN THE FLY IT LIES PUT
INTO PLACE AND ANOTHER ISSUES
REGARDING DIRECTOR COMPENSATION
AND IN THE INTEREST OF TIME HALL
ON THE NOT GO INTO THE DETAILS
DESCRIBING HOW DIRECTOR
COMPENSATION AND SAT.
A BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT IT IF INDEED
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR YOU.
AND LIKEWISE I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
PREVALENCE OUR STATISTICS
REGARDING.
AND THE COMPOSITION OF CORPORATE
BOARDS AND TO THE EXTENT YOU
HAVE IT WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
AND IT WILL USUALLY LIMITED TO
TWO SO I JUST I I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S TWO OTHER PEOPLE SAID
THERE'S FOUR OF YOU THERE SO.
QUICK PARA MARKET BASED
PERSPECTIVE SO I AND MY NAME IS
EMILY I CO FOUNDED A HEDGE FUND
ANTI SOCIALIZING INVESTING IN
MICRO CAPS STOCKS ON ACTUALLY OF
THIS TABLE ON THE PERSON WHO
SITS ON A PUBLICLY TRADED BOARD --
MICROCAP BOARD AND AT THAT POINT
I JUST WANTED TO BRING UP REALLY
QUICKLY IS --
YOU WITH SOME OF THE LARGEST IN
AMERICA AYE THERE HAS BEEN SOME
TINY MOVEMENT WITH WOMEN ONBOARD
THIS CONSTANT PUBLICITY WHICH IS
GREAT.
I'M.
BASED ON IMMENSE PRESSURE FROM
AND SOME OF THE BEST RUN
INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS LIKE
HELPERS CAO STIRS AND DIANE
BLACKROCK SO I WORK IN THE MICRO
CAP WORLD AND AS WE ALL KNOW
SMALL COMPANIES MICROCAP
COMPANIES ARE THE ENGINE THAT
DRIVES THE ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE NATION AS A WHOLE.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO QUICKLY
TELL YOU ABOUT MY WORLD WHERE
THOSE INSTITUTIONAL FORCES ARE
NOT IN PLAY BECAUSE CALPERS CAL
STIRS BLACKROCK THEY'RE SO BIG
THEY HAVE SO MUCH MONEY UNDER
MANAGEMENT THEY CAN'T DEPLOY
THEM IN THE SMALL COMPANIES IT
JUST DOESN'T WORK.
SO I WANT TO AN INVESTOR
CONFERENCE TWO WEEKS AGO
MICROCAP COMPANIES MY FUHRMAN I
MET WITH I'M FORTY THREE
COMPANIES REPRESENTING YOU KNOW
TWO HUNDRED NINETY DIRECTORS.
AND I HAD MY ANALYSTS LOOK UP
THE WOMEN DIRECTORS AND OUT OF
THAT TWO HUNDRED NINETY AND YOU
CAN ALL GAS IN YOUR HEAD HOW
MANY THINK THOSE WERE WHEN.
AND AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT
THERE'S TWELFTH --
OUT OF TWO HUNDRED NINETY TO
HIGH AND I ALSO JUST WANTED TO
NATURALLY QUICKLY I I AM A
CERTIFIED DIRECTOR ON THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN ACTS
INVESTMENT BANKER LAWYER I COULD
GO ON AND ON IT TOOK ME SIX
YEARS TO GET ON A BOARD.
AND THE REASON I FINALLY GOT A
BOARD SEAT IS BECAUSE THE
COMPANY ADDED A SEATS --
SO.
I WOULD ALSO BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT I MEAN THE
INTERFACE BETWEEN CAPITAL
MARKETS AND ONE OF THE FEW
FEMALES THAT WORKS AS AN
INVESTOR AND AS A BOARD MEMBER.
SO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THROUGH THE REAL WORLD ON
THE STAFF THINK YOU THINK YOU.
AND FINAL THOUGHTS QUICK THE
GREAT PLAINS AMY BERNARD VAUGHN
AND I'VE BEEN ABOUT A TWENTY
YEAR CORPORATE CAREER IN VARIETY
OF ROLES THE CHARGE.
CORPORATE COMPLIANCE AT LARGE
COMPANIES MY COUSIN ONLY ONS
FIREMAN'S FUND --
THAT I'M AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
STATE BAR I GUESS I WOULD JUST
SAY AND I CHAU WOMEN OR 47% OF
OUR LABOR FORCE.
THEY'RE ONLY 16% OF WOMEN THAT
ARE REPRESENTED ON PORTS AND I
REALLY FEEL THAT CALIFORNIA
CORPORATIONS ARE DISADVANTAGED.
BY THIS LACK OF GENDER DIVERSITY
AND IT'S A REALLY EXCITING
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
LEAD.
IN THIS AREA --
AND CREATE A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE FOR OUR BUSINESSES
GREAT STATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
I'M AND STAINS MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I REPRESENT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I AM ALSO A WOMAN
BUSINESS OWNER MYSELF.
AND VERY HEARTILY SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS REPRESENT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION BUSINESSES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE ARE MANY QUALIFIED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LAURIE CAMERA SMALL
BUSINESS CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN LANG ON
PAYER BEHALF OF MAYOR MARK
FARRELL IN THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI JENNIFER MANUAL MCO VIA
CONSULTING GROUP AND THE CHAIR
OF THE WOMEN AND GIRLS
ADVANCEMENT COALITION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MAUREEN LANE NAM OWNER OF OUR
OUR STRATEGIES A CONSULTING FIRM
IN SACRAMENTO AND I'M ON THE
BOARD OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND I
WILL ASK AND THAT WE MAKE ROOM.
FOR THE OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ONE GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER BROWN BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE OPPOSED SB.
TWENTY SIX I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
THE POLICY I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
HAVING MORE WOMEN ON BOARDS --
I WOULD AT SOME POINT LEAD TO
SERVE ON A BOARD MYSELF BUT THE
POINT IS IS THAT THE WAY IN
WHICH THEY'RE GOING THAT
PROPOSAL'S GOING ABOUT DOING IT --
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND JUST AYE
JEOPARDIZES OUR DAY FIRST EAGLES
AND OTHER POTENTIAL AREAS SO THE
BE A BILL BASICALLY REQUIRES A
MINIMUM QUOTA.
OF A CERTAIN NUMBER OF WOMEN ON
A BOARD AND WHILE A LOT OF OUR
CORPORATION CERTAINLY --
STRIVE AND ARE SEEKING TO
ACHIEVE HAVING WOMEN ON THE
BOARD THERE ALSO TRYING TO
DIVERSIFY THEIR BOARD POSITIONS
IN MORE THAN JUST WITH REGARDS
TO GENDER.
AND SO IF YOU HAVE A TO POLICY --
EQUALLY QUALIFIED ONE MAY
SATISFY ANOTHER DIVERSITY --
CONCERN OR ACHIEVEMENT FOR THE
CORPORATION OTHER THAN JUST
GENDER AND YOU SPECIFICALLY SAY
IN THIS BILL THAT YOU HAVE TO
SATISFY MINIMUM QUOTA WITH
REGARDS TO GENDER YOU'RE
DISQUALIFIED OTHER CANDIDATES
THAT MAY SERVE OTHER DIVERSITY
PRACTICES FOR THE CORPORATION.
OTHER THAN JUST GENDERS WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THAT US PER.
EXPECTED AS WELL I'M WILL THOUGH
ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH REGARDS
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY WE HAVE AN
EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE AND OUR
FEDERAL CONSTITUTION WE HAVE A A
CAN.
OF SIMILAR EQUAL PROTECTION
CLAUSE UNDER A CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION ARTICLE ONE SECTION
EIGHT SAYS THAT NO PERSON CAN BE
DISQUALIFIED FROM A PROFESSIONAL
VOCATION BASED UPON A LISTA
PROTECT CLASSIFICATIONS
INCLUDING GENDER AND AGAIN.
IF IT YOU GOT TO QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES ONE THAT IS MALE ONE
THAT IS FEMALE AND UNDER THIS
BILL YOU SPECIFICALLY HAVE TO
HIRE SOMEBODY TO SATISFY THE
QUOTA YOU'RE MAKING A
DISQUALIFICATION SPECIFICALLY
BASED UPON GENDER WHICH WE
BELIEVE WOULD VIOLATE THE
CONSTITUTION.
SECONDLY OUR THIRD LEAVE --
THERE'S ALSO AN ISSUE WITH
REGARD STICK OF THE INTERNAL
AFFAIRS DOCTOR AND FOR CORPORATE
GOVERNANCE OF THE INTERNAL
AFFAIRS STOCKTON TRIES TO
PREVENT CONFLICT OF LAWS BETWEEN
DIFFERENT STATES AND THE
INTERNAL AFFAIRS DOCTRINE
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT THE LAW
IN WHICH THE A CORPORATION IS.
A INCORPORATED WILL DICTATE
THEIR INTERNAL AFFAIRS MEANING
THE VOTING OF THEIR DIRECTORS
HOW THEIR BOARD OF DIRECTORS IS
GOVERNED ECCENTRIC BECAUSE THEY
THEY DON'T WANT.
A DIFFERENT STATES FROM WHERE
THAT BUSINESSES LOW DISTANCE
STANDARDS WITH REGARDS TO THOSE
INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
THE BILL IS NOT APPLICABLE TO
ONLY THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
INCORPORATED HEREIN CALIFORNIA
IS APPLICABLE TO THOSE ON
COMPANIES THAT ARE BASICALLY
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THEN YOU HAVE THIS CONFLICT
OF INTEREST WITH REGARDS TO THE
INTERNAL AFFAIRS DOCTRINE.
WHICH WILL LEAVE IS ANOTHER ON
CHALLENGE FOR THE LEGALITY OF IT
SO AGAIN WE DON'T DISAGREE WITH
THE IDEA OF THE BILL TO
ENCOURAGE MORE WOMEN ON THESE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS WHICH IS
FILLED THE WAY IN WHICH THE
PROPOSAL IS GOING.
IS BOTH UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
WILL BE LEGALLY CHALLENGED INTO
THE INTERNAL AFFAIRS DOCTOR AS
WELL FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE TO STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION ROSS
BUCKLEY WITH THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION POSTS THE
MEASURE.
THERE THOMAS OF HALF BACK COME
IN OPPOSITION.
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS EIGHT DO WANT TO
CLARIFY SOMETHING THAT THIS.
IS THE JURISDICTION OF THIS
BANKING COMMITTEE OVERSEES
CORPORATE GOVERNANCE AND
ANYTHING RELATED TO THE
CONSTITUTION CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF THIS BILL WILL BE DEALT WITH
IN JUDICIARY.
SIRA GONZALEZ FLETCHER I WANNA
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORTH DO
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS AND
JUDICIARY I'M.
I HOPE IT'S CONSTITUTIONAL --
BUT I JUST WANNA KNOW BECAUSE I
I DO FIND IT A LITTLE OFFENSIVE --
TO BE LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION --
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO SATISFIED
BEING BOTH GENDER AND RACIALLY
DIVERSE SO AM I DON'T THINK THAT
WE NEED. TO TO SUGGEST THAT IT
IS A DISCUSSION BETWEEN MEN OF
COLOR AND WHITE WOMEN SO THAT
WAS PERSONALLY OFFENSIVE TO ME --
SO WITH THAT I THINK IS OUR
MOTION IF NOT I'LL BE HAPPY MAKE
MISSION. TO BE AT THE SECOND
[inaudible]
AFFECTED THANK YOU.
ARE RATES AND THEN WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND CHEN THAT
SUMMER GRAYSON.
SENATE JACKSON AND I DO
APPRECIATE BRING THIS
INFORMATION CONTINUE TO LIGHT
AND I'VE BEEN REALLY BLESSED TO
WORK WITH THE WOMAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS HERE THAT HAVE EDUCATED
ME GUIDED ME THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND ALSO HAVE A TEAM.
OF A WOMEN OVER 60% ON MY TEAM
THAT'S A ARE HARD WORKING
DILIGENT.
AND I NOTICED THAT.
YOU WERE JERSEY SCRIPTING WAY
WHEN THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THIS BILL
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE AN
ANSWER FOR IT.
AND I JUST WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON IT.
IN TERMS OF AND FOR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS THAT THE BILL A CUP.
THE BILL THAT THE SUGGESTION
THAT THERE'S CONSTITUTIONAL
PROBLEM WITH CHOOSING A WOMAN
OVER MAN ON THE BOARD IS A FALSE --
ANALOGY BECAUSE WHAT THE BILL
DOES IS IT CALLS FOR THE
ADDITION.
OF A POSITION ON THE BOARD SO
WE'RE NOT KICKING ANYBODY OFF TO
PUT A WOMAN ON I IF THE COMPANY
AND IN PART THE PROBLEM TOO IS
THAT.
THE TURNOVER RATE UNEASE PLUM
POSITIONS IS VERY LIMITED AND
THE IT SO WHAT THIS WOULD DO IS
SAY LOOK IF THERE HASN'T BEEN AN
OPENING --
ANNA OF YOU DON'T HAVE A WOMAN
ON THE BOARD BY TWENTY NINETEEN
YOU AT A POSITION TO ABORT.
AND THAT POSITION WE SHOULD FIND
THE BEST QUALIFIED PERSON AND I
KINDA GET A LITTLE INSULTED TO
WITH THE SUGGESTION THAT --
YOU KNOW IF IT'S A QUALIFIED.
MAN IN A QUALIFIED WOMAN IN YOU
GIVE THE POSITION THE WOMAN THEN
YOU'RE TAKING AWAY FROM US BUT
PROBABLY MORE QUALIFIED MAN.
MEAN THE PROBLEM WE'VE HAD IS
THAT FOR DECADES AND HUNDREDS OF
YEARS THIS IT THE ONLY PEOPLE OR
DETERMINE TO BE QUALIFIED BEEN
MEN.
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE I MEAN THE NOTION THAT 40%.
OF THE CORPORATIONS A IN IN
CALIFORNIA BELIEVE WAS DON'T
HAVE ANY WOMEN ON THE BOARDS WHY
WHY IS THAT BECAUSE THERE HAS
BEEN THIS SORT OF BLANKET
DISCRIMINATION SO RATHER THAN
PLAY THAT GAME.
WERE SAYING OKAY YOU CAN KEEP
YOUR BOARD THE WAY IT IS WHICH
IS GOING TO ADD A POSITION AND
WE NEED TO ADD WOMEN FIND.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THERE ARE
SOME INCREDIBLY.
THAT STANFORD ACTUALLY HAS IT'S
A BUSINESS SCHOOL HAS ITS OWN
REGISTRY THE HARVARD BUSINESS
SCHOOL HAS ITS OWN REGISTRY OF
WOMEN A QUALIFIED WOMEN I'VE
LOOKED AT SOME OF THESE
REGISTRIES.
THESE PEOPLE WILL CERTAINLY
QUALIFIED TO BE PRESIDENT THE
UNITED STATES BUT THEN AGAIN I
WILL GO INTO THAT BUT BUT IT
RIGHT.
YOU SAID IT NOT ME BUT BUT THE
POINT IS THE POINT IS THAT THESE
ARE EXTRAORDINARILY QUALIFY
PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN A
CHANCE AND IN GREAT MEASURE
BECAUSE AS WAS POINTED OUT THIS
HAS BEEN SORT OF A WHITE MAN'S
BASTION FOR YEARS.
AND SO BASICALLY I I WAS JUST
WRITING DOWN THE YOU KNOW THERE
ARE A FEW ISSUES AND THEY WILL
BE TAKEN UP WE ADDRESS SOME OF
MY OWN --
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND I
THINK ONCE WE ONCE WE OPEN THOSE.
DOORS WE WILL FIND THAT NOT ONLY
WILL WE HAVE MORE WOMEN AND
WOMEN OF COLOR AND WE WILL HAVE
PEOPLE OF COLOR BECAUSE WE WILL
HAVE.
A AB BASICALLY TAKEN THE
CHALLENGE OF FINDING THE BEST
QUALIFIED PEOPLE FOR THESE
POSITIONS IRRESPECTIVE OF THEIR
GENDER IRRESPECTIVE OF THEIR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION PERSPECTIVE
OR OF THEIR OF REYES SORT.
I MEAN THAT WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS
WE HAVE HAD A GLASS CEILING AND
A CEILING THAT HAS BEEN.
A TO A PLACE WITH THAT THE
THERE'S NO DOOR EXCEPT FOR WHITE
MEN.
THAT'S BEEN THE PROBLEM AND SO
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS SAYING
OKAY GUYS YOU HAVE YOUR YOU HAVE
YOUR C. SUITE BUT WE'RE GOING TO
JUST ADD A POSITION AND ADD A
WOMAN TO THAT.
AND I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU WITH
IT IN A COURSE OF A VERY SPORTS
WILL LOOK LIKE THE FACE OF
CALIFORNIA AND NOT THE FACE OF
THE AUGUSTA.
GOLF CLUB.
A IS THAT WHAT IT IS THEY ARE
THINGS I WOULD THINK YEAH
SENATOR I KNOW ACTUALLY WHAT WE
WILL HOLD OFF THAT WAS ADDRESSED
TO THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL.
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATOR TAXPAYER YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
I WAS RAISED FOR THE VERY STRONG
MOTHER WHO LET ME KNOW VERY
CLEAR.
THAT -- I
WAS TO HONOR AND OBEY HER AND
SHE HAD THE SHE HAD THE RIGHT TO
ADD TAKE ME OUT AND THAT WAS NOT
ON A DATE.
A AND THE LITTLE AND A WOMAN --
YES AND SO I I WOULD DARE NOT --
STAND AGAINST THIS NOR --
NOT SUPPORTED IN FEAR THAT SHE
WOULD VISIT ME TONIGHT FROM HER
GRAVE.
A HOWEVER HAVING SAID THAT AND
AGAIN I DO APPRECIATE IT I HAVE
NOTICED OR OR I EXPERIENCE
SOMETHING THAT JUST A LITTLE
TESTIMONY POSSIBLY.
TO HAVE BE ENCOURAGING AND AND I
WAS DOING A TOWN HALL AWHILE
BACK.
AND THE SUBJECT HAD COME UP OF
EQUITY AND AND AS A GENDER
EQUITY.
AND IT WAS VERY CLEAR AND ONE
FEMALE SPEAKER GOT UP AND SAID
SOMETHING REALLY PROFOUND SHE
SAID WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR YOU
MEN TO LEAVE THE ROOM.
WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR YOU TO
MAKE ROOM IN.
AND I THAT REALLY RESONATED WITH
REALLY REALLY WELL WITH AND AND
STUCK WITH ME EVEN TO THIS DAY.
AND OUT I DO HAVE A QUESTION AND
THAT IS I I HEARD YOUR RESPONSE
TO CONSTITUTION THAT OF THE AND
I UNDERSTAND JUDICIOUS GONNA
TAKE THAT UP TOMORROW.
HOWEVER WHEN YOU DO AT ON THAT
SEAT AND THEN THAT SEAT WOULD BE
VACATED BY A FEMALE AT THAT
POINT DO YOU ENTER INTO THE
CHALLENGE THAT WERE FACING NOW
WITH POSSIBLY A QUOTA OR AT HOW
WOULD.
A HOW WOULD THAT WORK VENN ONCE
THE SEATS ALREADY BEEN CREATED
AND OCCUPIED AND THEN VACATED.
THEN YOU SPECIFICALLY ONLY LOOK
FOR THAT ONE GENDER.
I'D DOES THAT CREATE A PROBLEM
OR ARE WE OKAYED BY THAT POINT
[inaudible]
WELL I YOU KNOW I'M NOT SURE
THIS IS THIS WE ARE BASICALLY
SAYING THAT WE WANT TO HAVE.
A CERTAIN EQUAL REPRESENTATION
ON THESE BOARDS.
ARM AND YOU KNOW I SUSPECT I
SUSPECT THERE WILL BE A
CHALLENGE NO MATTER WHAT WE DO
BUT I THINK.
A I THINK WE HAVE ADDRESSED THE
PROBLEM AS BEST WE CAN WE THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE.
OKAY IT MAY ULTIMATELY TURN OUT
THAT YOU KNOW WHO KNOWS WHAT THE
SUPREME COURT'S GONNA DO ONE ANY
GIVEN DAY.
BUT MY HOPE IS BY THEN WE'VE
BROKEN THE LOGJAM AND WHICH TO
START LOOKING FOR THE BEST
PEOPLE FOR THE JOB I APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU [inaudible]
A REP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE CENTER FOR
BRING THIS BEFORE I THINK IT'S
AN EXCELLENT IDEA I'M LOOKING
FOR TO SUPPORTING AND I THINK
I'M.
IN ADDITION IT TO THE GENDER
EQUITY BENEFITS ACTION IT'S
GONNA BUT BENNETT THE BUSINESS
BENEFIT THE BUSINESS SECTOR PARA
CALIFORNIA I THINK BRINGING
THESE PERSPECTIVES INTO THE
BOREDOM IS GONNA HELP OUR
BUSINESSES AND HELP OUR ECONOMY
AND SO.
I'M LOOKING FOR TO SUPPORTING
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND THAT'S WHAT THE
RESEARCH SHOWS GREAT THANK YOU I
THINK YOU A SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THANK YOU A
COLLEAGUES.
FOR ENGAGING IN AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION THAT I THINK IS ON
TIME TO BE HAD.
AND I DO WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
ABILITY TO CLOSE --
ENJOYED THE CONVERSATION I THINK
YOU KNOW WHY I REALLY THINK THIS
IS A GREAT BILL AND AND ONE WE
CAN REALLY MOVE THE BALL FORWARD
HERE.
I THINK IT'S TIME.
MAYBE WAY BEYOND TIME BUT WITH
THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THIS MOTION HAS
DO PASSED TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LIMON AYE LIMON AYE CHEN.
CHEN NOT VOTING ACOSTA
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA I THINK GABRIEL.
I QUEBRA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THOSE FLETCHER AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE STEINORTH
[inaudible]
STONE.
STONE AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I ALRIGHT THE BILL IS
[inaudible]
IS OUT SEVEN OH WE WILL DO AND
THANK YOU SO THE BILL IS AT
SEVEN KNOWING THANK YOU WE HAVE
A MODEM FOR THE CONSENT AND A
SECONDS.
SO WE WILL TAKE THE ROLE FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THINK YOU THINK
HERE.
WE'RE TAKING A ROLE FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND WE'RE GONNA
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASSED AND SENT.
LIMON I LIMON HIGH CHEN.
CHEN AYE ACOSTA [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
BURKE I GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE GABRIEL.
CAROL I GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE STEINORTH
[inaudible]
STONE.
STONE AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HIGH.
ALRIGHT THE CONTENT IS OUT NOW
WE WILL GO THROUGH AS THE THREE
BILLS. TO DO ADD ONS WE WILL
START WITH A S. B. N.. EIGHT TWO
SIX JACKSON.
BUSH'S DO PASSED GRAHAM
JUDICIARY [inaudible]
ACOSTA [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
BUT I STEINORTH.
ALL RIGHT THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT
ZERO NOW WE ARE MOVING ON TO
ITEM.
S. B.. TEN EIGHTY SEVEN THAT'S
ROTH.
MOTION DO PASSED COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
[inaudible]
BURKE I GABRIEL.
GABLE AYE STONE [inaudible]
STONE HIGH.
THAT BILL IS OUT ELEVEN NO.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO SP.
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE GLAZIER.
CLOSEST TO PASS BURKE
[inaudible]
BURKE I STONE [inaudible]
STONE I THAT BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
NINE OH SAID [inaudible]
WHO NEEDS YOU NEED TO AT NO OKAY?
NO ADDITIONAL VOTES [inaudible]
A CONSENT.
YOU'RE GOOD THANK YOU.
I SAID THE CONSENT AGENDA ITEM
INCLUDES SP.
TEN FIFTY FIVE MOTIONS DO PASS
ACOSTA [inaudible]
ACOSTA I ALRIGHT THAT BILL IS
OUT TEN OH WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN OUR BANKING HEARING